I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Happy birthday, everybody. It is Michael's birthday. Michael, it should be day. Oh my gosh. Oh, Angela, he would be so happy if anyone responded to his birthday like that. Yeah. This guy needs a party like nobody else. He needs the party. It's so true, guys. It's season two, episode 19, Michael's birthday written by Lee Eisenberg and Gene Stupnitsky,
我是珍娜·费舍。而我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您制作《办公室》的终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女郎们。祝大家生日快乐，迈克尔。今天是迈克尔的生日。迈克尔，今天是属于你的日子。哦，天哪。哦，安吉拉，如果有人那样对他的生日做出反应，他会非常高兴的。是的。这家伙太需要一个派对来庆祝了。他真的很需要这个派对。千真万确，伙计们。这是第二季第19集，迈克尔的生日，由李·艾森伯格和吉纳·斯图普尼斯基编剧，
directed by Ken Whittingham. Guys, I'm in my closet right now. I am in my That's What She Shed. This morning, my husband figured out how to try to soundproof it, Sam. I don't know if we did it. We tried, but we got a shower curtain out of the guest room. And Josh put it across the shed and hung some blankets on it. We took, you know, the clamps that our kids have a fort building kit? Wow. And we took all of their clamps. So I hope the kids don't get to do a fort this week because mom is trying to podcast from home. The best part of seeing you right now on this video chat while we do this is that you are wearing a set of gamer headphones. Yes, I am. I have a giant microphone, but I've pointed
由肯·惠廷厄姆执导。伙计们，我现在在我的衣帽间里。我正在我的“她之所 shed（小木屋）”里。今天早上，我丈夫萨姆想出了一个如何给它隔音的方法。我不知道我们成功了没。我们试过了，从客房拿了一条浴缸浴帘。乔什把它挂在小木屋上，还在上面挂了一些毯子。我们拿了，你知道的，我们孩子搭堡垒用的夹子吗？哇。我们把他们所有的夹子都拿走了。所以我希望孩子们这周别想搭堡垒了，因为妈妈正试图在家录播客。现在在这个视频聊天中看到你，最棒的部分是你戴着一套游戏玩家耳机。是的，没错。我有一个巨大的麦克风，但我把它指向
it up to the sky like an antenna coming out of your ear. Yeah. And we're going to put a photo of this on the pod. Should I do a summary? Here it is. Do a summary, babe. I don't know why I called you, babe. I don't know. I don't know either. Do a summary, babe. It's Michael's birthday and he is desperate to be the center of attention. Meanwhile, we learn that Kevin is waiting for the results of a mole biopsy. Yes. Kevin is very worried. He might have skin cancer and this is causing a distraction to Michael's birthday that he is unhappy with. Oh my gosh. Michael's like, today is the day for celebration and you guys are all worried about Kevin and I am grumpy about it. Yeah. There's my summary.
天空，就像一根从你耳朵里伸出来的天线。是的。我们打算把这张照片发到播客上。我要做个总结吗？来吧。做个总结吧，宝贝。我不知道我为什么叫你宝贝。我不知道。我也不知道。做个总结吧，宝贝。今天是迈克尔的生日，他极度渴望成为注意力的中心。与此同时，我们得知凯文正在等待肿块活检的结果。是的。凯文非常担心。他可能患有皮肤癌，这导致迈克尔的生日受到了干扰，对此他很不高兴。哦，天哪。迈克尔觉得，今天是庆祝的日子，而你们都在担心凯文，我对这感到很不爽。是的。这就是我的总结。
I like it, babe. Babe, I like it. Babe. Okay. Wait, are we just going to jump right in? No, there's more. There's more summary and fast facts. You've forgotten everything. Wow. There's more summary. What is happening? Also, in this episode, Dwight and Angela really bicker over who exactly is in charge of planning Michael's birthday party. Is it Dwight as his right-hand man or is it Angela, head of the PPC? This is the first time we're going to see a little tension going on between Dwight and Angela. Yeah. Well, I mean, there was tension in season one over who was the security officer, you know, that was pre-them dating. So they have some issues about who gets to have control of what. They had that going
我喜欢它，宝贝。宝贝，我喜欢。宝贝。好吧。等等，我们这就直接切入正题吗？不，还有呢。还有更多总结和快速事实。你把什么都忘了。哇。还有更多总结。发生什么事了？此外，在本集中，德怀特和安吉拉真的在争论到底谁负责策划迈克尔的生日派对。是作为得力干部的德怀特，还是PPC（派对策划委员会）负责人安吉拉？这是我们第一次看到德怀特和安吉拉之间产生了一点紧张气氛。是的。嗯，我是说，第一季里关于谁是保安人员就产生过紧张气氛，你知道的，那是他们约会之前的事。所以他们对于谁来掌控什么有一些分歧。他们带着这种关系进入
into this relationship and I have a note card, guys, that says, Dwangel assess. Oh, Dwangel assess. All through this episode. We're going to track it. Also in this episode, Jim and Pam, they sneak out of the office together and in the end, the entire office gang is going to go ice skating. Who saw that coming? I didn't see that coming. Well, the writers knew that we were going to end up at an ice skating rink. That leads me into Sam. Please play my special audio clip. Fast facts. What is that? What is happening? We had a fan submit some little, they're called stings, Angela. I love that so much. I didn't even know there was such a thing. Yeah. Thank you. So more stings, please. More stings, guys. Send us
这段关系，我有一张便签，伙计们，上面写着“德怀特-安吉拉评估”。哦，德怀特-安吉拉评估。贯穿这一集。我们会追踪它的进展。此外在本集中，吉姆和帕姆一起溜出了办公室，最后，整个办公室的一帮人要去溜冰。谁能料到这一点？我可没料到。好吧，编剧们知道我们最后会去溜冰场。这正好引出了萨姆。请播放我的特殊音频剪辑。快速事实。那是什么？发生什么事了？我们有粉丝提交了一些小片段，它们被称为“刺痛音效（stings）”，安吉拉。我太喜欢这个了。我甚至不知道还有这种东西。是的。谢谢。所以请播放更多刺痛音效。更多刺痛音效，伙计们。给我们发送
your stings. I didn't even know that was a term. We're learning so much. We're 100, but thank you for making us stings. So fast fact number one is that Steve Carell is a very, very good ice skater. He played hockey growing up. He played pickup hockey every week as an adult. Fan question from Matt Loveless. Was the plot built around Steve's ability to ice skate? Yes. He's so good. He's really good. Yes. The writers had on one of their cards up on the wall this fact about Steve being a good ice skater and they had been looking forever for a way to incorporate it. And you guys might remember that later when we filmed the threat level midnight, that again, that plot of threat level midnight,
你们的刺痛音效。我甚至不知道那是个专业术语。我们学到了好多。我们已经录了100期了，但谢谢你们为我们制作刺痛音效。所以快速事实一：史蒂夫·卡瑞尔是一个非常非常好的溜冰高手。他从小就打冰球。成年后他每周都打野球。来自马特·洛弗斯的粉丝提问：剧情是围绕史蒂夫的溜冰能力构建的吗？是的。他太棒了。他真的很厉害。是的。编剧们把史蒂夫擅长溜冰这个事实写在墙上的卡片上，他们一直在寻找各种方法将其融入剧情中。大家可能还记得，后来当我们拍摄《威胁等级：午夜》时，那个《威胁等级：午夜》的电影情节，
the movie, takes place in an ice skating rink. And that was just like another opportunity to feature Steve's ice skating ability. I was at the car wash one time waiting for my car to get washed, right? You know, the one you kind of, you can drive through part of it and then you wait on the other side, right? Yeah. So I'm at the car wash and this guy walks up to me and goes, I ice skate with Steve. Just, you know, sometimes I ice skate with Steve. And I was like, Oh, what? Oh, okay. Way to go. You're probably very good because Steve is good. Have a nice day. Well, you know, Angela, my husband Lee ice skates. He's on several pickup hockey teams and my son as well is a hockey player and my husband
又发生在溜冰场里。这只是又一个展示史蒂夫溜冰技能的机会。我有一次在洗车行等车洗干净，对吧？你知道那种你可以开车穿过一部分，然后等在另一侧的那种洗车行，对吧？是的。所以我在洗车行，一个家伙走过来对我说，我和史蒂夫一起溜冰。就是，你知道的，有时我和史蒂夫一起溜冰。当时我就想，哦，什么？哦，好吧。真了不起。你可能溜得很好，因为史蒂夫很厉害。祝你过得愉快。嗯，你知道吗，安吉拉，我丈夫李也溜冰。他参加了好几个野球冰球队，我儿子也是个冰球运动员，我丈夫
now plays on the pickup team that Steve used to play on. I wonder if he plays with the guy from the car wash. Steve does not play pickup hockey anymore. He told me he kind of retired from that. But back when we shot this episode, he was really into it. He was really into it. And Jenna, you're like a hockey mom. I have been on the ice with you now and I've met your hockey mom friends and I am into it. I don't have a kid that plays hockey, but they told me you can drink beer at like 10 a.m. hockey matches and I'm like, Oh, yeah, this is the crowd I should be in. I mean, I'm over at the soccer field. They got nothing at that concession stand, maybe some pretzels. I mean, we're at these hockey rinks sometimes
现在加入了史蒂夫以前常去的那个野球队。我在想他是不是跟洗车行的那个家伙一起打球。史蒂夫不再打野球了。他告诉我他已经算是退出了。但当我们拍摄这一集的时候，他真的很热衷于此。他真的非常喜欢。而且珍娜，你就像个冰球妈妈。我现在已经跟你一起上过冰面了，我还见到了你的冰球妈妈朋友们，我也迷上这事了。我没有孩子打冰球，但他们告诉我你甚至可以在早上10点的冰球比赛时喝啤酒，然后我就想，哦，是的，这正是我应该混的圈子。我是说，我常去足球场。他们的小卖部里什么都没有，可能只有一些饼干。我是说，我们有时在早上七点或八点
at seven in the morning or eight in the morning and they open up that concession stand and they go for it. I am not a beer drinker, but I am amazed at people's ability to, uh, to have a beer in the morning. Last a beer in the morning. I'm like, that would do me in. But yeah, oh God, I love the hockey community. It's a great, it's a great, great community. I love being a part of it. All right. Fast fact number two, this is a fan question from Renata. She said, this episode has several external locations. Did it take longer to produce this episode because of that? So we usually would take five days to shoot an episode and we were still able to shoot this episode in five days, even with our multiple locations.
就到了这些冰球场，他们会打开小卖部，大家就开始畅饮了。我不是个爱喝啤酒的人，但我真的很佩服大家早上就能喝上一杯的本事。大清早就喝啤酒。我觉得这会把我整垮。不过，天哪，我太喜欢冰球社区了。这是一个非常棒、非常棒的社区。我很高兴能成为其中一员。好了。快速事实二，这是一个来自雷纳塔的粉丝提问。她说，这一集有几个外景。因为这个，制作这一集花的时间更长吗？所以我们通常拍一集需要五天时间，尽管有多个外景拍摄地，我们仍然能够在五天内完成这一集的拍摄。
And guess what I did, Angela? What? I got some scoop from Kentopedia about our locations. Kent's a borneck. Let's hear it. All right. So first up, the store that Jim and Pam go to was a ride aid at Woodman and Sherman Way. Do you remember that ride aid, Angela? I do. I do. I pass by it every day on the way to work and I would shop there constantly. Yeah. I would always like pick up some milk on the way home. One time I bought some socks. I was low on socks. Oh, yeah. I remember setting up my trailer, you know, we would sort of decorate and I got a few different little things. I got like a doormat. Yeah. At that ride aid. Okay. So cute. You were at the ride aid by us. He said that we shot there for
你猜我从肯托百科（Kentopedia）那里打听到了什么，安吉拉？什么？我打听到了一些关于我们拍摄地点的内幕消息。肯·泽博内克。说来听听。好的。首先，吉姆和帕姆去的那个商店是伍德曼街和谢尔曼路交界处的莱德艾德（Rite Aid）药妆店。你还记得那个莱德艾德吗，安吉拉？我记得。我记得。我每天上班路过它，而且我经常在那里购物。是的。我总是在回家的路上顺便买点牛奶。有一次我买了一些袜子。我的袜子快穿完了。哦，对。我记得布置我的拖车，你知道的，我们会稍微装饰一下，我买了一些小东西。我买了一个门垫。是的。就在那个莱德艾德。好吧。太可爱了。你就在我们附近的那个莱德艾德。他说我们在那里拍了
a half a day, but we started very, very early. I think my hair and makeup started around 4 a.m. or 4 30 a.m. I believe it because yeah, we had to start shooting on camera by six and the ride aid said we could only shoot there until 11 a.m. with the store closed. After 11 a.m., we could keep shooting, but they were going to let customers in. And Kent said that we finished by 10 a.m. We finished an hour early and that all the customers that you see in those scenes are hired background performers. None of them are real customers. All right. Good job team. Good job. You got in. You got out. That's the scoop on the ride aid. So the ice skating, we shot that at Pickwick ice rink in Burbank. I know this
半天，但我们开始得非常非常早。我想我的发型和化妆大约在凌晨4点或4点半就开始了。我相信，因为是的，我们必须在六点前开始在镜头前拍摄，而且莱德艾德说我们只能在商店关闭的情况下在那里拍摄到上午11点。11点之后，我们可以继续拍摄，但他们要让顾客进来了。肯说我们在早上10点就拍完了。我们提前一个小时完成了拍摄，你在那些镜头中看到的所有的顾客都是雇来的临时演员。他们都不是真正的顾客。好吧。干得好，团队。干得好。你们进去了。又出来了。这就是关于莱德艾德的内幕。至于溜冰的戏，我们在伯班克的皮克威克溜冰场拍摄的。我很熟悉这个
rink well and we had the whole place to ourselves for one full day. We were there from 7 a.m. to 7 p.m. Again, we started our hair and makeup very early around 5 a.m. and we were all shooting by 7 p.m. The other skaters in the background were background actors. We shut that place down. It was all hours. So Kent also told me that luckily both Randall Einhorn and Matt Sehn, they were our camera operators that they could ice skate. And so they were skating around with cameras. Do you remember that, Angela? Because I did not remember that those guys were skating with us. I remember Randall on the ice. I do because I have a little funny backstory about there was a stunt ice skater. Jenna, do you remember the stunt ice skater?
溜冰场，我们一整天都包下了整个地方。我们在那里待了从早上7点到晚上7点。同样，我们的发型和化妆开始得非常早，大约在早上5点，我们在7点前就开始拍摄了。背景中的其他溜冰者都是背景演员。我们把那个地方包下来了。那是全天候的。肯还告诉我，幸运的是兰德尔·因霍恩和马特·森，他们是我们的摄影师，他们都会溜冰。所以他们带着摄像机在冰上滑来滑去。你还记得吗，安吉拉？因为我不记得那些家伙当时跟我们一起溜冰了。我记得兰德尔在冰上。我记得，因为我有一个有趣的幕后故事，当时有一个替身溜冰演员。珍娜，你还记得那个替身溜冰演员吗？
Oh, yeah. The guy who filled in for Oscar. Yes. So you'll see later in the episode as we watch it that Oscar is like a very good ice skater. He does like a kind of a pure wet and spins around. Well, that's because there was a stunt guy that looked like him that was a really great figure skater. And I have a little story about that. I don't know if you remember this, Jenna, but Randall was filming the stunt guy getting all of the moves, right? Yeah. And they wanted us skating in the background. And I sort of skated in the background and I did a big circle. Like I kind of opened my legs and did a big circle. And the guy said to me in between takes, he goes, hey, he said, can you skate? And I was
哦，对。代替奥斯卡的那个家伙。是的。所以稍后大家在观看这一集时会看到，奥斯卡是一个溜冰高手。他会做那种类似转圈和旋转的动作。嗯，那是因为有一个长得很像他的替身演员，他是一个非常出色的花样滑冰运动员。我有一个关于这的小故事。我不知道你还记不记得，珍娜，兰德尔当时正在拍摄替身演员完成所有动作的过程？是的。他们想让我们在背景里溜冰。我当时就在背景里溜冰，转了一个大圈。我好像叉开双腿转了个大圈。那个家伙在两场拍摄间隙对我说，嘿，他说，你会溜冰吗？然后我
like, well, I can roller skate. So I'm just trying to do what I do on roller skates. And he said, come here. And he spun me around. And then Randall was like, oh, wait, I'll get this just in case maybe it'll be funny that Oscar spins Angela or something. You know, okay. And so the stunt ice skater started doing all these things with me, Jenna. He spun me. He picked me up and twirled me. He had me stick one leg out and one leg up, like, like, and then and like spun me and set me down. And we like somewhere there is footage of the stunt ice skater lifting me in the air and spinning me around. And it where is this footage? We never use the footage. But it really made me laugh to think that
说，嗯，我会溜轮滑。所以我就照着我在轮滑时的样子做。然后他说，过来。然后把我转了一圈。接着兰德尔就说，哦，等一下，我把这个拍下来，以防万一奥斯卡旋转安吉拉或者别的什么会很有趣。你知道的，好吧。于是那个溜冰替身演员开始跟我一起做所有这些动作，珍娜。他转动我。他把我抱起来转圈。他让我伸出一只腿，抬起一条腿，就像，就像，然后像把我转了一圈又放下来。我们像，某个地方有那个溜冰替身演员把我举到空中并转圈的镜头。那这个镜头在哪里？我们从没用过这个镜头。但一想到
maybe there is a world where Angela and Oscar figure skate together. Okay, two things. Number one, NBC released this footage immediately. Number two, Angela, do you know who that guy was? I looked him up. Okay, his name is Bert Jude Landkin. Okay. And he was a pair skater, a famous pair skater who won the silver medal at the 1982 United States Figure Skating Championships and then later placed sixth at the 1984 Winter Olympic Games. Wow. You were figure skating with an Olympic pairs figure skater. Where is this footage? That is amazing. That is so cool. Well, you know, I'm not very good, but he was very good. So, well, I'm going to find the footage for you. I'm going to surprise you with it at some milestone birthday
也许在某个世界里，安吉拉和奥斯卡会一起滑花样滑冰，我就觉得非常好笑。好吧，两件事。第一，NBC立刻把这段镜头放出来。第二，安吉拉，你知道那个家伙是谁吗？我查过他。好吧，他的名字叫伯特·裘德·兰金。好吧。他是一个双人滑运动员，一个著名的双人滑运动员，曾在1982年美国花样滑冰锦标赛上获得银牌，后来在1984年冬季奥运会上获得第六名。哇。你当时在和一个奥运会双人花样滑冰运动员一起滑冰。这段镜头在哪里？这太惊人了。太酷了。好吧，你知道的，我滑得不是很好，但他非常厉害。所以，好吧，我会为你找到这段footage的。在未来的某个里程碑式生日上
in the future. You'll have to ask Randall Einhorn, say Randall, did any of that like end up somewhere? Oh my gosh. Okay. Well, next up is Fast Fact number three, but I don't even know how to follow that because that was good stuff. Picture me and Oscar right now in your mind, guys. Close your eyes. Picture me and Oscar right now as a figure skating couple on the ice and go. Oscar makes all of our costumes. Well, Angela, that is a good segue for me into Fast Fact number three because you mentioned costumes. We got a fan question from Alyssa and this is not specific to this episode, but a general fan question and I thought it was a good one. So I thought we would include it. Alyssa wants to know, what do you do with
我会用它给你一个惊喜。你得去问问兰德尔·因霍恩，说兰德尔，那些东西有没有流落到什么地方去？哦，天哪。好吧，接下来是快速事实三，但我甚至不知道该怎么接话了，因为刚才那个太棒了。伙计们，在脑海里想象一下我和奥斯卡现在的样子。闭上眼睛。想象一下我和奥斯卡现在作为冰上花样滑冰搭档的样子，走吧。奥斯卡制作了我们所有的服装。好吧，安吉拉，这正好顺理成章地引出了我的快速事实三，因为你提到了服装。我们收到了来自艾丽莎的粉丝提问，这不是针对这一集的，而是一个普遍的粉丝问题，我觉得挺不错的。所以我想我们应该把它包含进来。艾丽莎想知道，
your clothes after you've been shooting in the same outfit for 12 to 15 hours at a time? She says, I imagine they would get stretched out and wrinkly and dirty. Do you have multiple sets of the same outfits for each day of shooting or does someone wash them for you? First of all, I like where her head's at. Yeah. I like this person. I know. This person is a planner. She probably packs very well for a trip. I like it. I like your train of thought. These are things I wonder about when I watch movies, especially if I see a movie where like it's a flood or they're submerged in water somehow. I think, oh my gosh, how many hours that day did they have to stand like waist deep in water? Probably like 12 hours. So here's the
当你们连续12到15小时穿着同一套衣服拍摄后，你们会对衣服做什么？她说，我想它们会被撑得变形、满是褶皱而且很脏。你们每天拍摄时都有多套相同的服装，还是有人帮你们洗？首先，我喜欢她的思路。是的。我喜欢这个人。我知道。这个人是个计划通。她去旅行时可能行李收拾得很好。我喜欢。我喜欢你的思路。这些是我看电影时会好奇的事情，特别是如果我看到一部电影里面有洪水或者某种程度上他们被水淹没。我想，哦，天哪，那天他们得在齐腰深的水里站多少个小时？大概12个小时吧。所以情况是这样的。我们经常有，呃，我们总是有复本。他们想确保每套衣服你都有两套。
thing. We often had, well, we always had duplicates. They wanted to make sure that you had two of every outfit. So they could wash and have the next set ready the next day. Also, if you were to spill something on it or get a tear or whatever, they would have the duplicate ready to go. Yes. And if you did have to do some sort of a stunt or something in that particular outfit, then they might have even more than two. They might have seven shirts if part of the scene involves you purposely dripping ketchup on your shirt or something. So yeah, they always had multiples. And part of the wardrobe department's job is to launder and prepare your outfit for the next day. So that's how that worked. I like the question
这样他们就可以清洗并在第二天准备好下一套。此外，如果你不小心把什么东西洒在上面或者弄破了之类的，他们也有准备好的备用服装。是的。如果你真的必须在那套特定的服装里做某种特技或类似的事情，那么他们可能会有不止两件。如果你戏里的一部分涉及你故意把番茄酱滴在衬衫上或者别的什么，你可能会有七件衬衫。所以，是的，他们总是准备有多件。服装部门的工作之一就是清洗并为第二天准备好你的衣服。事情就是这样的。不过我喜欢这个问题。
though. I like the question. All right. That's the end of my fast facts. Oh, I'm so sorry, guys. What the f*** was that? Well, I think my bread is done. I have some bread in the oven. I thought that was like an alert. They always say you can tell something about the person by which alarm they pick. And by they, I mean me. This is my theory. So like your alarm is like gang, gang, gang, like mayday, mayday. And like my alarm, my alarm is like two banjos playing. Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding. Oh, Angela, this is saying everything about us. That's 100% true. Everybody, what is your alarm on your phone and what does it say about
我喜欢这个问题。好了。我的快速事实到此结束。哦，非常抱歉，伙计们。刚才那是什么鬼？好吧，我想我的面包烤好了。我烤箱里烤着面包。我还以为那是个警报器呢。他们总说你可以通过一个人选择的闹铃看出他的性格。这里说的“他们”指的就是我。这是我的理论。所以就像你的闹铃是那种，当，当，当，就像求救，求救。然后像我的闹铃，我的闹铃就像两把班卓琴在弹奏，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮。哦，安吉拉，这把我们的性格全暴露了。百分之百正确。大家，你们手机的闹铃是什么，它又说明了关于你的
you. Lee is telling me that the internal temperature of my bread is only 154 degrees. Do you mind if we take a break? I do want to take a break because my That's What She Should is really cold and I turn my heater off when we podcast and I want to warm it back up. So you take care of your bread, you heat up your bread, I'm going to heat up my She Should. And we'll be right back. Well, I just oversaw the bread. We're still not at the right internal temperature. I had to leave it for Lee to make a judgment call. I hope it turns out. I hope we can make some sandwiches today. Time will tell. Let's get back on track, Jenna. And let's jump into this episode. Yes, the cold open. Michael is trying to sell the employees some calling cards.
什么。李告诉我，我面包的内部温度只有154华氏度。你介意我们休息一下吗？我是想休息一下，因为我的“她之所 shed”真的很冷，而且我录播客时把暖气关了，我想把它重新开暖和一点。所以你去处理你的面包，把你的面包加热，我去把我的 shed 加热。我们马上回来。好吧，我刚才没注意把面包烤过头了。内部温度还是不对。我只好把它留给李去作判断了。希望最后能成功。希望我们今天能做几个三明治。拭目以待吧。我们回到正题上来，珍娜。让我们切入这一集吧。是的，开场白。迈克尔正试图向员工们推销一些电话卡。
Mm-hmm. Did you notice something about this scene, Jenna? It's in the conference room, right? Yep. Yeah. Who all is in attendance? Who? Jim Dwight. Jim Dwight, Toby, Creed, Oscar, Ryan, and Stanley. Not a single woman. Hey. Hey. Now, do you think, A, Michael thinks the women will say this is a load of crap, but he thinks the guys will go along with it? Why aren't there any women? Jim convinces Michael that this is a pyramid scheme. Michael draws a chart, and then Jim turns it into a literal pyramid. Do you remember in the fire episode when Michael said he lost all of his money in a pyramid scheme, and that's why he couldn't go to business school?
嗯哼。你有没有注意到这个场景的什么细节，珍娜？它在会议室里，对吧？没错。是的。都有谁出席了？谁？吉姆、德怀特。吉姆、德怀特、托比、克里德、奥斯卡、瑞恩和斯坦利。没有一个女性。嘿。嘿。现在，你觉得，A，迈克尔觉得女性会认为这是胡扯，但他觉得男士们会顺从他？为什么没有女性？吉姆说服迈克尔这是一个传销骗局。迈克尔画了一张图表，然后吉姆把它变成了一个真正的金字塔。你还记得在火灾那一集里，迈克尔说他在一个金字塔骗局中输光了所有的钱，这就是为什么他不能去商学院吗？
Yeah. Toby brings it up in this scene. Yeah. Toby's like, remember? Well, Toby brings up an email scam that Michael also participated in. Yes, and Michael's like, hey, when the son of the deposed king of Nigeria emails you directly, asking you for help, okay? His father ran the freaking country, okay? Yeah. Michael. Michael. Michael. All right, so that's our cold open, and then when the episode begins, that was one of those standalone cold opens that did not end up applying. I have one more question about the cold open. You might know the answer. Oh, go ahead. Is a calling card the same as a business card? What, Angela?
是的。托比在这场戏里提到了这一点。是的。托比就像是，还记得吗？好吧，托比提到了迈克尔也参与过的一个电子邮件诈骗。是的，迈克尔就像是，嘿，当被废黜的尼日利亚国王的儿子直接给你发邮件向你寻求帮助时，好吧？他的父亲经营着整个该死的国家，好吧？是的。迈克尔。迈克尔。迈克尔。好吧，这就是我们的开场白，然后当这一集真正开始时，那是一个没有实际后续影响的独立开场白。关于开场白我还有最后一个问题。你可能知道答案。哦，请说。电话卡和名片是一回事吗？什么，安吉拉？
What's a calling card? Wait, no, you're not asking this question. Do you not remember the 80s? Honey, I was in, oh, I just called you honey. I'm a baby, I'm a honey. Honey, I was in Jakarta, Indonesia until 1984. What happened? What's the calling card? Okay, gosh, how do I describe it? You know how long-distance phone calls, they would cost money, like so much money per minute if you wanted to call someone, and you would usually just use your home phone, and then I can't believe I'm describing this right now. Okay. Wait, so it's like a card with a number on it and you enter it or something, and then you use the minutes? Yes, it's like a prepaid credit card that you could apply to the price of a phone call. Okay, I know what it is now.
什么是电话卡？等等，不，你不是在问这个问题吧？你不记得80年代了吗？亲爱的，我当时在，哦，我刚叫你亲爱的。我是个宝藏，我是个亲爱的。亲爱的，我1984年以前一直住在印度尼西亚雅加达。发生了什么？什么是电话卡？天哪，我该怎么形容它呢？你知道长途电话，如果你想给某人打电话，它们会花钱，每分钟要花好多钱，你通常只会用家里的座机，然后我真不敢相信我正在这样描述它。好吧。等等，所以它就像是一张上面有号码的卡片，你输入它或者别的什么，然后使用通话分钟数？是的，它就像一张预付信用卡，你可以用它来支付电话费。好吧，我现在知道了。
I got it. I remember that for whatever reason in my mind, I thought this whole scene was about business cards, and I thought it was really funny. Oh, and that's funny. So anyway, and I was like, oh, look, they're making their own business cards. That's kind of cute. No, no. You don't need fill in his corvette for that. Now this makes sense. Yeah. Okay, I hear the tone in your voice, Jenna. I hear it. Well, I don't know how to end this. I hear it. It's like you pity me, but you love me, but you're perplexed that a grown woman doesn't know what a calling card is. I hear it all. It's all there, but I love you. Okay, so they weren't business cards, they were calling cards. All right, I love you, babe. I love you, babe. I love you, honey. Go. That was the
我明白了。我记得不管出于什么原因，我脑子里一直以为整个场景是关于名片的，而且我觉得这真的很好笑。哦，那挺搞笑的。所以无论如何，当时我就想，哦，看，他们正在制作自己的名片。那挺可爱的。不，不。你不需要为此填满他的克尔维特跑车。现在这就说得通了。好吧。我听得出你语气的变化，珍娜。我听出来了。好吧，我不知道该怎么结束这个。我听出来了。就好像你在同情我，但你又很爱我，不过你对一个成年女性居然不知道什么是电话卡感到迷惑不解。我全听出来了。都在那儿了，但我爱你。好吧，所以它们不是名片，它们是电话卡。好吧，我爱你，宝贝。我爱你，宝贝。我爱你，亲爱的。走吧。那是
cold open. It was a standalone cold open, right? It doesn't apply to the rest of the episode, because after the credits, we're going to learn the real plot of this episode when Michael enters and Pam, while handing him his messages for the day, says, happy birthday, Michael. And when he enters, he's carrying like his own box of donuts for his birthday. Is he carrying the balloons that we're going to see later in his office? Probably. I couldn't track where the balloons came from, but then Michael has a talking head where he tells us that people go crazy for his birthday. They go nuts. They just go all out. They go all out. And it's just a boring shot of the office, just everyone doing work. Yeah. No one paying attention. And then Jenna, he says
开场白。那是一个独立的开场白，对吧？它跟这一集的其余部分没关系，因为片头过后，当迈克尔走进来时，我们将了解这一集的真正剧情。帕姆一边把当天的留言递给他，一边说，生日快乐，迈克尔。当他走进来时，他手里提着一箱他自己的生日甜甜圈。他提着我们稍后会在他办公室看到的那些气球吗？可能是的。我没法追踪这些气球是从哪里来的，但随后迈克尔有一个单人镜头，他在镜头里告诉我们，人们对他的生日疯狂极了。他们简直要疯了。他们会全力以赴。他们会大肆庆祝。而这只是办公室的一个无聊镜头，大家都在干活。是的。没有人理会他。然后珍娜，他说
that he shares a birthday with Eva Longoria. And I looked up her birthday. It's March 15th. Jenna, yours is March 7th. Yeah. That means you and Michael Scott are both Pisces. We're both Pisces. Which I also looked up, and this was what I found on the internets about Pisces. You, Jenna Fisher, and Michael Scott. Are you ready? I'm ready. In all matters of life, you bring intensity and passion. This explains why you will devote an endless amount of time and effort into anything that you feel is worthwhile, especially family and loved ones. Hey, I know. That sounds like a compliment. I think it is. You are giving me a compliment. I am giving you a compliment. Thank you. So now, Jim has a talking head. Well, wait, wait, wait. Before we get to that, I think
他和伊娃·朗格利亚同一天生日。我查了她的生日。是3月15日。珍娜，你的是3月7日。是的。这意味着你和迈克尔·斯科特都是双鱼座。我们俩都是双鱼座。我还查了一下，这是我在网上找到的关于双鱼座的描述。你，珍娜·费舍，还有迈克尔·斯科特。准备好了吗？我准备好了。在生活的方方面面，你都带来了强度与激情。这就解释了为什么你会把无穷无尽的时间和精力投入到你认为有价值的任何事情中，尤其是家庭和挚爱。嘿，我知道。听起来像是个赞美。我想是的。你这是在夸我。我是在夸你。谢谢。所以现在，吉姆有一个单人镜头。哦，等等，等等。在我们谈到那个之前，我觉得
something really important happens here, which is Kevin is late for work. Now, we don't know why yet, but he's late. He seems a little preoccupied. And when he walks in, Michael's like, you're late, but you're forgiven because Doth it is my birthday. This made me laugh. Michael's such an idiot. I love him. But yes, Kevin is late. So, and then we go to Jim's talking head. Well, here's something I want to say about Jim's talking head. So the meat of the talking head is he's just kind of describing what Michael is like on his birthday. But look at the winter backdrop behind him. So you know how we... You love this. You love this so much. You know I love our backdrops. Okay, so that's not a real window to the outside. That's just a window to a printed backdrop that we would
这里发生了一件非常重要的事，那就是凯文上班迟到了。现在，我们还不知道原因，但他迟到了。他看起来有点心神不定。当他走进来时，迈克尔说，你迟到了，但你被原谅了，因为Doth今天是我的生日。（注：Doth为模仿圣经古语）这把我逗笑了。迈克尔真是个白痴。我爱死他了。但确实，凯文迟到了。所以，然后我们切到了吉姆的单人镜头。好吧，关于吉姆的单人镜头我想说点什么。所以这个单人镜头的核心内容是他在描述迈克尔过生日时的样子。但看看他身后的冬日背景。所以你知道我们……你太喜欢这个了。你太喜欢这个了。你知道我有多爱我们的背景。好吧，所以那不是通往室外的真正窗户。那只是一扇通往印有背景画面的窗户，我们会
change seasonally. And I just noticed that the backdrop is winter. It looks like it's maybe snowy. And I'm going to bring this up later. So put a pin in that. But I just want to say winter backdrop behind Jim. I am riveted. I am riveted. I cannot wait. Oh, it's going to pay off later. I cannot wait for this payoff of the winter backdrop. All right. So then we see Meredith and Kevin in the break room. And she says, did you hear anything yet? And so we start to see like what's happening with Kevin, right? That he might have a skin cancer scare. Yeah. And this storyline starts. And then we go to Dwight in Michael's office. There is no one more excited for Michael's birthday than Dwight. Really? I mean, it is such a special day for him. It is a huge day. If only
按季节更换它。我刚刚注意到那个背景是冬天的景色。看起来好像下雪了。我待会儿会提起这个。所以先留个心眼。但我只想说吉姆身后的冬日背景。我被迷住了。我被迷住了。我迫不及待了。哦，它待会儿会发挥作用的。我迫不及待地想看到这个冬日背景的回报了。好吧。然后我们看到梅雷迪思和凯文在茶水间。她说，你听到什么消息了吗？于是我们开始看到凯文身上发生了什么，对吧？他可能遇到了皮肤癌恐慌。是的。这条故事线开始了。然后我们去到迈克尔办公室里的德怀特那里。没有人比德怀特更对迈克尔的生日感到兴奋了。真的吗？我是说，对他是如此特殊的一天。这是一个巨大的日子。如果只有
everyone were reacting like Dwight, Michael would be happy. Michael reveals he's wearing a new suit. He says it's from Italy. No, Bulgaria. Right. New suit. And Dwight said maybe he'll have to get one. And Michael's like, good luck. It's pinstriped, I noticed. And the tie is insane. It's a crazy tie as well. This is also the scene where Michael tells Dwight that he's not worried about his birthday because the PPC has been working 24 sevens since yesterday. But also it's in the scene that Dwight actually begs Michael if he can be in charge of Michael's birthday. So this is setting up like what's going to be a big source of tension between Angela and Dwight. And I think Angela, you know, thinks that Michael's an idiot and thinks that Dwight is loyal to someone who
每个人都像德怀特那样反应，迈克尔就会很高兴了。迈克尔透露他穿着一件新西装。他说那是来自意大利的。不，保加利亚的。对。新西装。德怀特说也许他也得去买一件。迈克尔却说，祝你好运。我注意到它是细条纹的。领带也很疯狂。那领带简直疯狂。这也是迈克尔告诉德怀特他并不担心自己的生日，因为PPC从昨天开始就一直在全天候7天24小时工作的场景。但也是在这个场景中，德怀特实际上恳求迈克尔让他负责迈克尔的生日。所以这就为安吉拉和德怀特之间将成为巨大紧张之源的事情做好了铺垫。我觉得安吉拉，你知道的，觉得迈克尔是个白痴，并且觉得德怀特对一个
doesn't deserve like his loyalty. And so she's just already she already is like annoyed that is Michael's birthday. And now on top of the fact her boyfriend wants to be the party planning, you know, committee chairman. Well, Angela must be very conflicted because as party planning committee head, she is obligated to celebrate this birthday. Yes. Yes. Even though she feels that Michael is kind of going a little bit over the top, right? Yes. Well, Angie, the next scene is the party planning committee scene. One more thing before we move on there is a famous meme that came out of this Dwight and Michael scene. It is the raise the roof. Oh, the raise the roof. Yes. Yes. Yes. And in the super famous meme, it's even longer in the
不值得他效忠的人保持忠诚。所以她已经开始，她已经因为今天是迈克尔的生日而感到恼火了。现在再加上她的男朋友想当派对策划委员会主席的事。好吧，安吉拉一定内心非常纠结，因为作为派对策划委员会负责人，她有义务庆祝这个生日。是的。是的。尽管她觉得迈克尔有点太夸张了，对吧？是的。好吧，安吉，下一个场景就是派对策划委员会的场景。在继续之前还有一件事，从这个德怀特和迈克尔的场景中诞生了一个著名的迷因。那就是“举起屋顶（raise the roof）”。哦，举起屋顶。是的。是的。是的。而在那个超级著名的迷因中，在删减片段里其实更长，伙计们。所以如果你去看看删减片段，真的非常搞笑，因为当德怀特开始做那个动作时，迈克尔说，不，我不是这样教你的。很显然他们练习过这个动作。哦，我太喜欢了。我很高兴能有一个额外的举起屋顶的删减片段。好吧，接下来是派对策划委员会的会议。天哪，这是OG（元老级别）。这是OG。那是菲利斯、安吉拉和帕姆。就这样。宝贝，我不知道什么是OG。我当时不知道。这就是今天的OG。珍娜。好吧。上网查查看，女士。那是什么？你可能知道什么是电话卡，但让我告诉你什么是OG是什么意思。它的意思是元老级黑帮，原始匪帮。就像，你是做这件事的第一个人，无论是什么。我不知道。在城市词典上查一下。
deleted scenes, you guys. So if you check out the deleted scenes, it's really funny because when Dwight starts to do it, Michael's like, no, that's not how I taught you. Like clearly they've practiced this move. Oh, I love that. I love that there's an extra deleted scene of that raise the roof. Well, next up is the party planning committee meeting. Lady, it's the OG. It's the OG. It is Phyllis, Angela and Pam. That's it. Baby, I don't know what OG is. I did. That's what it is today. OG. Jenna. Okay. Get on the internet, lady. What is it? You might know what a calling card is, but let me tell you what OG is. It means original gangster, original gangster. It's like, you are the first person of this thing, whatever. I don't know. Look it up on Urban Dictionary.
所以这是OG。PPC的。PPC的。哦，我想要一件印有“PPC元老”的连帽衫。不。那太棒了。哦，看看我用的这个咖啡杯。我用的是PPC元老杯。你今天用的是PPC的咖啡杯。耶。这很应景。那是另一个词，安吉拉。应景（Apropos）。我知道那是什么意思。意思是恰当。是的，我懂。好吧。好吧。所以他们在这次会议上进行了引人入胜的对话。他们想知道我们应该在什么时候把蛋糕拿出来。一点或者一点半。帕姆打了个哈欠。哦，等等。是的。帕姆打了个哈欠。帕姆说一点钟，安吉拉立刻接话说一点半，然后帕姆就打了个哈欠。是的。然后安吉拉对她冷嘲热讽。是的。她就像是，哦，不好意思。我们无聊到你了吗？嗯，你知道的，在删减片段里。
So it's the OG. Of the PPC. Of the PPC. Oh, I want a hoodie that says OG of the PPC. Nope. That'd be great. Oh, look at the coffee mug I'm using. I'm using the OG PPC. You're using PPC coffee mug today. Yay. That's apropos. That's another word, Angela. Apropos. I know what that means. It means appropriate. Yeah, I got it. Okay. All right. So they're having a riveting conversation in this meeting. They want to know what time we should bring out the cake. One or one 30. Pam yawns. Oh, wait. Yeah. Pam yawns. Pam says one o'clock to which Angela immediately says one 30 and then Pam yawns. Yeah. And then Angela sasses her. Yeah. She's like, oh, I'm sorry. Are we boring you? Well, you know, there's in a deleted scene.
我即兴发挥了一句台词，我说的是“菲利斯才不无聊”。是的。你还记得吗？我记得。我记得。然后我们都笑了。我们以前拍这些PPC场景时经常笑。好吧，他们会放任我们自由发挥。他们会给我们几句台词，然后就让我们自由发挥。我们会有意即兴表演最无聊的对话。我们会像是，嗯，我不知道，伙计们，我对纸盘有什么看法。我是说，我们应该买多大尺寸的？我们应该买大号椭圆形的吗？没人买椭圆形的。谁会买椭圆形的纸盘？没有人。我觉得我们应该买方形的，方形纸盘。我们可以把这种无聊的对话进行好久。那是因为格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）非常喜欢PPC。我知道。他太喜欢我们那些世俗平凡的闲聊了。他喜欢这种动态。所以他会让我们无休止地聊下去。我太喜欢了。是的，太
I improvised a line where I said not Phyllis. Yes. Do you remember that? I do. I do. And then we all laughed. We used to laugh a lot when we did these PPC scenes. Well, they would let us go. They would give us a few lines and then they would just let us go. And we would improvise the most boring conversations on purpose. We'd be like, well, I don't know, guys, how I feel about paper plates. I mean, which size should we get? Should we get the large oval one? No one gets oval. Who gets an oval paper plate? No one. I think we get the square one, square paper plates. We would do this for so long. That's because Greg Daniels loved the PPC. I know. He loved our mundane banter so much. He loved the dynamic of it. And so he would let us just go on forever. I loved it. Yes, it was
有趣了。好吧，接着德怀特进来了，他告诉我们迈克尔想要恶作剧蜡烛。是的，他给我们列了一张单子，迈克尔想要的惊喜清单。这就是安吉拉告诉德怀特这是个闭门会议的时候。好吧，是的，迈克尔想要恶作剧蜡烛。他想要一个脱衣舞电报。然后安吉拉说，不，不，这是个闭门会议。接着德怀特和安吉拉之间产生了一种奇怪的、对视。帕姆则是一脸“这到底是怎么回事”的表情。是的。我也有一个粉丝捕捉到的细节。什么？这是一个来自“性觉醒（Sexually Woke）”的粉丝捕捉。这个人写信说，当你们谈论脱衣舞电报时，菲利斯在第4分钟第19秒时笑场了。我第一次看的时候没有注意到这一点。但我看到了。她露出了一个小坏笑。我觉得你
so fun. Well, then Dwight enters and he tells us that Michael wants trick candles for his cake. Yeah, he gives us a list, a list of surprises that Michael would like. And this is when Angela tells Dwight that this is a closed door meeting. Well, yeah, Michael wants trick candles. He wants a stripper gram. And Angela's like, no, no, it's a closed door meeting. And then there's this sort of odd, like, stare off between Dwight and Angela. And Pam is like, what is happening? Yes. I have a fan catch as well. What? This is a fan catch from Sexually Woke. This person wrote in to say, Phyllis is breaking at four minutes, 19 seconds when you talk about the strip of gram. I did not notice this the first time I watched it. And I saw it. She gets a little smirk. And I think you
可能会以为那是角色菲利斯。但是安吉拉，我们了解菲利斯。我觉得这是一个真实的菲利斯式的微笑。我敢肯定是。我们在那些场景里笑了很多次。所以我很喜欢这个。我要回去找找那个镜头。太可爱了。我还想指出的是，当雷恩进出门口时，约翰不在背景中的办公桌前。所以他逃掉了部分背景工作。干得好，约翰。真会偷懒，溜出那个镜头。我知道。我猜他当时在干嘛，他大概是在自己的拖车里和布赖恩一起玩《麦登橄榄球》或者别的什么。是的，他们在玩《麦登橄榄球》。每当他们有空闲场景时，他们就会这么干。而且他们会大喊大叫。他们声音好大。你还记得吗？他们声音太大了。他们会像是，
could think it was Phyllis the character. But Angela, we know Phyllis. And I think this was a real Phyllis smile. I'm sure it was. We laughed a lot in those scenes. So I love that. I'm going to go back and look for that. That's so cute. I also want to note that when rain comes in and out of the door, John is not at his desk in the background. So he bailed on some background work. Way to go, John. Way to be sneaky and get out of that scene. I know. I guess what was he, he was probably playing Madden football in his trailer with Brian or something. Yes, they were playing Madden football. That's what they would do in their downtime when they had scenes. And they would yell. They were so loud. Do you remember? They were so loud. They'd be like,
拿到它。抓住他。好吧。在第4分钟第35秒，我们现在看到了迈克尔办公室里迈克尔和简之间的这通电话。是的。珍娜，你有没有注意到谁在迈克尔的房间里？瑞恩。瑞恩就坐在那里听完全部的电话。而且这通电话太尴尬了。他就像是，嘿，我打电话给他了。今天是你的生日。而简却说，今天不是我的生日。然后他就像是，哦，我以为我们同一天生日。而她却说，不是。接着她说，生日快乐，迈克尔。然后她又说，我们是在被拍摄吗？而他则说，没有，绝对没有。然后他说，简，有什么话尽管说在心里好了。结果她不是直接就挂断了吗？咔哒，拨号音。而整个过程瑞恩都坐在那里。
get it. Get him. All right. So at four minutes, 35 seconds, we now have this phone call between Michael and Jan in Michael's office. Yeah. And Jenna, did you catch who is in the room with Michael? Ryan. Ryan is sitting there for the whole phone call. And the call is so awkward. He's like, hey, I called him. It's your happy birthday. And she's like, it's not my birthday. And he's like, oh, I thought we had the same birthday. And she's like, no. And then she's like, happy birthday, Michael. And then she's like, are we being filmed? And he's like, nope, not at all. And then he says, Jan, just feel free to say whatever is in your heart. And then doesn't she just like hang up? Click dial tone. And the whole time Ryan is sitting here.
我有件事要指出来。如果你去看删减片段，这个场景其实有个开头。那就是临时工瑞恩被指派去在迈克尔的办公室里绑那些气球。所以这就是气球的来源。因此他和迈克尔在办公室里。瑞恩正在把气球绑在诸如他的椅子之类的东西上。然后他问，我可以走了吗？迈克尔却说，不行。太感谢你告诉我这个了，因为我一直很好奇那些该死的汽球是从哪来的？因为迈克尔走进来的时候手里可没拿气球。他一定是某种程度上命令临时工瑞恩去弄来的。这段删减片段就是证据。他强迫瑞恩留下来听电话。
And I have a little something to point out. If you go and watch the deleted scenes, there is a beginning to this scene. And that is that Ryan, the temp has been given the task to tie those balloons in Michael's office. And so this is where the balloons come from. So him and Michael are in his office. Ryan is tying a balloon to like his chair. And then he's like, can I leave? And Michael's like, nope. Thank you so much for telling me this, because I was wondering where did those dang balloons come from? Because Michael did not walk in with them. He must have somehow ordered Ryan the temp to get them. And this deleted scene is the proof. He makes them stay in for the phone call.
哦，天哪。太悲惨了。我真为那个场景里的瑞恩感到难过。好吧，接下来的场景也极其尴尬，因为迈克尔在厨房里，他就在那个甜甜圈盒子周围徘徊，等着有人来。然后当斯坦利走进来时，他说，哦，天哪，一定有人为了我的生日买甜甜圈来了。迈克尔，我们明明看到你刚来时拎着那个盒子。迈克尔，迈克尔，迈克尔，迈克尔，迈克尔，迈克尔。这里我有一点要指出来。所以你知道，在《酒水游轮》里，你和吉姆在长达27秒的沉默中对视，对吧？是的。27秒。是这样吗？27秒。没错。好吧。我想让你们知道迈克尔把手搭在那个咖啡壶上等有人进来，好让他
Oh, God. It's so miserable. I feel so bad for Ryan in that scene. Well, the next scene is very cringy as well, because Michael's in the kitchen and he is just hovering over this box of donuts waiting for someone. And then when Stanley comes in, he's like, oh my gosh, somebody must have brought in donuts for my birthday. Michael, we saw you carry that box in when you arrived. Michael, Michael, Michael, Michael, Michael, Michael. I have something to point out here. So you know, in booze crews, you and Jim look at each other for 27 seconds of silence, right? Yeah. 27 seconds. Is that right? 27 seconds. That's right. Okay. I want you to know how long Michael stood with his hand on that coffee pot waiting for someone to come in so he could
假装自己在给自己倒咖啡、假装对有人生日甜甜圈感到惊讶，他这样站了多久。他在纯粹的沉默中站了10秒钟。哇。现在，如果你想想一部电视剧，伙计们，让一个角色傻坐在那里等待别人注意到他，这可是相当长的一段时间。千真万确。太惊人了。10秒钟。他站在那里东张西望，等待有人走进来，足足有10秒钟。好吧，然后后来当托比进来时，太让人难过了。托比看到了甜甜圈，发现今天是迈克尔的生日，于是他给出了最由衷、最真诚的生日祝福。生日快乐，迈克尔。是的。然后迈克尔却表现得非常刻薄。迈克尔就像是，他甚至说，好吧，我想我是不会记得给你一个甜甜圈了。
act like he was pouring himself a cup of coffee, act surprised that there were donuts for his birthday. He stood there for 10 seconds of pure silence. Wow. Now, if you think about a TV show, you guys, that's like a long time to leave a character just sitting there waiting for someone to notice him. That is so true. That's amazing. 10 seconds. 10 seconds he stood there looking around waiting for someone to walk in. Well, and then later when Toby comes in, it's so sad. Toby sees the donuts and he finds out it's Michael's birthday and he gives the most just upbeat genuine, genuine happy birthday. Happy birthday, Michael. Yeah. And then Michael is so mean. Michael's like, he's like, well, yeah, I guess I'm not going to remember to give you a donut.
假装在给自己倒咖啡，假装对他的生日甜甜圈感到惊讶。他就那样站着，纯粹的沉默持续了十秒钟。哇。现在，如果你想一下电视剧，你们这些家伙，让一个角色就那样干坐着等别人注意到他，这时间可真够长的。确实如此。太惊人了。10秒钟。他站在那里东张西望，等了10秒钟等有人走进来。嗯，然后后来托比进来的时候，太让人难过了。托比看到了甜甜圈，他发现今天是迈克尔的生日，于是他送上了最乐观、最真诚、最真挚的生日祝福。生日快乐，迈克尔。是的。然后迈克尔太坏了。迈克尔的反应是，他觉得，好吧，是的，我想我不会记得给你一个甜甜圈了。
I know. He's such a turd to Toby and Toby was being so nice to him. I know. So also happening in this episode is everyone kind of learning about the fact that Kevin's waiting for these skin test results. So like Jim's in the, in the break room and they're talking about it and Kelly over here. Yeah. Kelly, you mean Mindy. Mindy over here. That is a Mindy Kaling talking head when she's like, oh my gosh, I never thought about death until Princess Diana's funeral, which was so sad. And then she pauses and she's like that and my sisters like, oh, it's such a dark, it's such a dark talking head. It's so dark. I don't know how Mindy got through that. She almost didn't. I want you to know, look at six minutes, five seconds. Mindy is so about to laugh.
我知道。他对托比太混账了，而托比对他是那么好。我知道。这集中还发生的事是，大家差不多都得知凯文在等皮肤测试结果。所以吉姆在茶水间里，他们正在谈论这个，凯利在这边。对。凯利，你是说明迪。明迪在这边。那是明迪·卡灵的面对镜头访谈，当时她说，哦天哪，我从来没想过死亡，直到戴安娜王妃的葬礼，太令人伤心了。然后她停顿了一下，接着说，还有这个，我姐姐说，这真是一个黑暗的，这是一个黑暗的面对镜头访谈。太黑暗了。我不知道明迪是怎么挺过来的。她差点就没挺过去。我想让你们知道，看第六分钟第五秒。明迪简直快要笑出来了。
She's barely holding it together. Well, then the accounting department is discussing Kevin's possible skin cancer, Angela. And you are, I mean, Angela Martin is a real downer. She's a little bit of a Debbie downer. I mean, Oscars like, you know what, I'm sure it's going to be fine. I'm like, don't give them false hope. You don't know that. Is that pragmatic? I think she is, you know, yeah, she's pragmatic. She doesn't need to see the rosy picture. She's like, just give me the stats. Yeah, what are the stats on this? The stats are you should be worried. Yeah. Yeah. That's what the stats say. So next up, Michael gets a delivery. Oh, man. But he thinks that the woman is his strippagram. He's so excited. He's giddy. He literally says, here we go.
她快要憋不住了。好吧，接着会计部在讨论凯文可能患有皮肤癌，安吉拉。而你，我是说安吉拉·马丁是个彻头彻尾的扫兴鬼。她有点像个扫兴鬼。我是说奥斯卡说，你知道吗，我确信会没事的。我就像是在说，别给她虚假的希望。你并不知道。这很务实吗？我觉得她是，你知道的，对，她很务实。她不需要看美好的景象。她说，直接把数据给我。好吧，这方面的统计数据是什么？统计数据是你该担心了。对。对。这就是统计数据所说的。所以接下来，迈克尔收到了一份快递。哦，天哪。但他以为那个女人是他的脱衣舞娘。他太兴奋了。他乐不可支。他简直说，我们走吧。
And then he has a line that made me laugh so hard. He's like, oh, this chair has arms. Is that going to be all right? I loved that line. That made me laugh so hard. He's like, it'll be fine. It'll probably, you'll work around it. I feel like Steve improvised that. I feel like he improvised that. I don't know. I don't know. But I bet you're right. I do. I wish I had the script for this one because I would look it up. But I feel like that feels like, that feels like something you notice in the moment. Right. Because they just pulled the chair aside and it had arms. And I think he saw it in the moment and he said it. That's what I, it feels very much like a Steve improv moment. Well, I do want to just give a shout out to this guest actor, Susan Foley, who played the delivery woman.
然后他有一句台词把我笑得不行。他说，哦，这把椅子有扶手。这样行吗？我太喜欢那句台词了。把我笑得前仰后合的。他说，没关系。可能，你会克服的。我觉得史蒂夫那是即兴发挥的。我觉得他是即兴发挥的。我不知道。我不知道。但我敢打赌你是对的。真的。我希望我有这一集的剧本，因为我会去查证。但我觉得那感觉像是，那感觉像是你在当下注意到的事情。对吧？因为他们刚刚把椅子搬到一边，而它有扶手。我想他在当时看到了就说出来了。这就是我，感觉非常像是史蒂夫的即兴发挥时刻。好吧，我只想向这位客串演员苏珊·弗利致敬，她饰演了快递员。
I thought she was great. She was fantastic. She played it super straight, super real, made it very, very funny. Her confusion was not overplayed. It was perfection. Yeah. Well done, Susan. And then we just find out some sad backstory of Michael's childhood. Jenna, his childhood breaks my heart. It breaks my heart. So we had this birthday party when he was seven. He was so excited. He said they got a pony and a cart and the pony gave him a rash and his mom rubbed cream on him for three hours. And then he missed the party. He said it was his worst birthday. Well, this is a runner and some of them got cut out. But Michael had this runner throughout this episode of all of his worst birthdays comparing it to this one. So this
我觉得她演得真棒。她太棒了。她演得非常正经、非常真实，演得非常非常搞笑。她的困惑没有过度夸张。简直完美。干得好，苏珊。然后我们发现了一些迈克尔童年的悲伤背景故事。珍娜，他的童年让我心碎。让我心碎。所以他七岁时办过这个生日派对。他非常兴奋。他说他们弄了一匹小马和一辆马车，结果那匹小马让他长了皮疹，他妈妈给他涂了三个小时的药膏。然后他错过了派对。他说那是他最糟糕的生日。好吧，这是一个贯穿全剧的笑点梗，其中一些被剪掉了。但迈克尔在这一集里一直有个贯穿的笑点，就是他所有最糟糕的生日，并把它们和这个进行对比，所以这个
guy has had a lot of bad birthdays. Well, he's going to get a pick me up from Dwight, who's going to play the recorder for him while he eats donuts. Dwight is playing Billy Joel, which is a runner on our show. We're constantly going to the Billy Joel music library on the office. I don't know why that is for the longest time. Of course Dwight calls him William Joel. And then Michael is just sort of lamenting how he's being treated in the office. And he says, I bet Luke Perry's friends don't treat him like this. And he references this poster that that this is what the delivery woman was delivering. It is a poster of James Dean, not of Luke Perry, that his mom sent him for his birthday. That's what his mom sent him.
家伙度过了很多糟糕的生日。好吧，德怀特会给他打气，他要在吃甜甜圈的同时为他演奏竖笛。德怀特在演奏比利·乔尔的曲子，这也是我们剧里的一个贯穿笑点。我们在《办公室》里经常使用比利·乔尔的音乐库。我不知道为什么会这样，持续了很长时间。当然，德怀特管他叫威廉·乔尔。然后迈克尔只是在感叹他在办公室里受到的对待。他说，我敢打赌卢克·佩瑞的朋友们不会这样对待他。他提到了这张海报，这就是快递员送来的东西。那是詹姆斯·迪恩的海报，而不是卢克·佩瑞的，那是他妈妈寄给他当生日礼物的。那是他妈妈寄给他的。
Now, do you think that his mom meant to send him Luke Perry? Or she meant to send him James Dean and Michael just mistook it for Luke Perry? Which, which one is Michael a fan of? Or neither? Is it just Michael's mom was like, I don't know what to give him? I think Michael is probably a fan of Luke Perry. And that's who his mom thought it was. That's what I think. I think I like that story. I don't know. But I, I mean, I feel like that's something my mom would do. Or my sister, when you're at Christmas, my sister got me a Green Bay Packers baseball hat. Yeah. And I was like, I don't, I don't get it. And she was like, well, you went to Baylor green and gold. Same colors. I was like, what? Same colors. Right. Same colors. Right. So I feel like that could be
现在，你觉得他妈妈是故意送他卢克·佩瑞的吗？还是她本想送他詹姆斯·迪恩，而迈克尔只是把它错当成了卢克·佩瑞？究竟，迈克尔是哪一个的粉丝？还是都不是？难道只是迈克尔的妈妈在想，我不知道该送他什么？我想迈克尔可能真的是卢克·佩瑞的粉丝。他妈妈也是这么认为的。我是这么想的。我觉得我喜欢这个故事。我不知道。但，我是说，我觉得这很像我妈会做的事。或者我姐姐，圣诞节的时候，我姐姐送了我一顶绿湾包装工队的棒球帽。对。然后我说，我，我不明白。她说，嗯，你去了贝勒大学，绿色和金色。同样的颜色。我就想，什么？同样的颜色。对。同样的颜色。对。所以我觉得这可能
sort of a mom moment. Angela, one year for Christmas, my mom got me from, I guess, a local art fair in St. Louis, a drawing of a woman and her cat. She got it for me because she knows I love cats. I'm going to post this on office ladies pod Instagram. Is she going to get upset with you? Is she going to say something? No, this is a running joke in our family now. It is, Angela, it is a, it is a, I don't know how to describe it. It is a drawing of a woman on all fours. What? In lingerie. Nope. With her tush in the air and the cat is rubbing seductively on the woman's tush. And your mom missed all that. She just thought it was a lady and her cat. Yes. So Angela, imagine me on Christmas morning. She hands me, I'm in like college when she gives me this.
算是一种妈妈时刻吧。安吉拉，我妈妈有一次圣诞节送给我的，我猜是来自圣路易斯的一个当地艺术集市，一幅画，画的是一个女人和她的猫。她送我是因为她知道我喜欢猫。我要把它发到“办公室女士”播客的Instagram上。她会生你的气吗？她会说些什么吗？不，这现在成了我们家的一个常年笑话。是的，安吉拉，这是一个，这是一个，我不知道该怎么形容它。这是一幅画，画的是一个四肢着地的女人。什么？穿着内衣。不。屁股翘在空中，然后那只猫在女人的屁股上极其诱惑地蹭来蹭去。而你妈妈完全没看出来。她只以为是一位女士和她的猫。是的。所以安吉拉，想象一下圣诞节早晨的我。她把这个递给我，我当时在上大学，她把这个给我。
I come home from college. I unwrap this box and I'm looking at like a semi pornographic drawing of a woman and her cat. It's like, mom, what is this present? And she goes, what do you mean? It's a lady who loves her cat. She loves that pussy so much. She's like, she loves, you love cats. And I'm like, mom, I do love cats, but what is happening? And I, she didn't need, she's still like, didn't see it. She's like, I don't get it. My sister died laughing. I don't know if we've ever laughed so hard on Christmas ever in my family. So now here's, I still have it. Where is it? I'll tell you, I keep it in a drawer, but every time my parents come to my house and stay in my guest room, I get it out and I put it on the nightstand. And then there it is. And I'm like,
我从大学回家。我打开这个盒子，然后我看到了一幅半色情风格的画，画的是一个女人和她的猫。就像是，妈妈，这是什么礼物？她说，你什么意思？这是一个爱猫的女士。她太爱那个小猫咪了。她说，她爱，你喜欢猫。我说，妈妈，我的确喜欢猫，但这到底是怎么回事？然后我，她没看懂，她到现在还是，没看出来。她说，我不懂。我姐姐笑得前仰后合。我不知道我们家有没有哪一次圣诞节笑得这么厉害过。所以现在，我还留着它。它在哪？我告诉你，我把它藏在一个抽屉里，但每当我父母来我家住在客房时，我就会把它拿出来，放在床头柜上。然后它就在那儿了。然后我就说，
mom, here's your gift you gave me. And she knows that I do that. She knows that I don't keep it out all the time. But I like, religiously, I put it out whenever they visit. I, and I will post a picture of it. I will post a picture of it. I love that story so much. I love it so much. That is something 100% that my dad would do. I have a story I will say for another one that my dad did, my dad bought a painting from a man on the side of the road. I'm going to save it. Because it was, it was a, it was a Valentine's gift. I'm going to save it. Okay. Where are we? Where are we? Dwight goes into the bullpen and he announces that it is 1123 AM the exact time of Michael's birth. And he suggests that everyone lift him up in his chair. Yes. It's a tradition.
妈妈，这是你送我的礼物。她知道我这么做。她知道我不是一直把它摆在外面。但我每次他们来拜访时，都会雷打不动地把它摆出来。我，我会把它的照片发出来。我一定会发一张照片。我太喜欢这个故事了。我太喜欢了。这绝对百分之百是我爸会做的事。我还有一个故事，我留着以后再说吧，关于我爸做的事，我爸从路边的一个人手里买了一幅画。我要留着。因为那是，那是，一个情人节礼物。我要留着。好吧。我们在哪？我们在哪？德怀特走进办公区，宣布现在是上午11点23分，也就是迈克尔出生的确切时间。他建议大家把他连椅子一起抬起来。对。这是一个传统。
They're going to hoist him up in the air. It's a tradition. Well, I caught something here. What? I want you to look at Phyllis in the background of this scene. At the very beginning of the scene, she is behind Dwight at her computer. And I think that they said action before she had a chance to clear her computer screen. Is it Gates? Is she looking at Gates? I don't know because she was, she did go on a long deep dive where she would look for Gates for a long time. She wanted a gate for her driveway. I don't know. I really tried to zoom in and see what it was. But what you have to see is that right at the top of the scene, she puts her hand up to cover up whatever is on her screen. And then at eight minutes, 53 seconds, when Michael comes out of his office, it's like a,
他们要把他抬到空中。这是一个传统。好吧，我在这里发现了一些东西。什么？我希望你看看这个场景背景里的菲莉丝。在这个场景刚开始时，她在德怀特身后的电脑前。我想他们喊开始的时候，她还没来得及清理她的电脑屏幕。是门（Gates）吗？她在看门吗？我不知道，因为她确实进行过一次长时间的深入搜索，她找了好久的门。她想为她的车道装一个门。我不知道。我真的试着放大想看看那是什么。但你必须看到的是，就在场景一开始，她就把手举起来遮住屏幕上的东西。然后在八分五十三秒，当迈克尔从办公室出来时，就像是一个，
it's a continuous shot when you come back to Phyllis, the Dunder Mifflin screensaver is up. Oh, she was quick. She was quick. Yeah. She, she puts her hand up and with her left hand, she's like closing out of whatever she was doing. I have such a vivid memory of our camera guys, Randall or Matt saying, Hey Phyllis, we can see the Gates on your screen. Because like for a year, she looked at Gates for her driveway. Oh, that makes me laugh. Well, it's at this point that Pam and Jim are in the kitchen. They are not participating in the hoisting of Michael. And Pam suggests to Jim that they sneak out and buy something for Kevin. Yeah. At 10 minutes, 33 seconds, you guys, we learn who Dwight tips and who he doesn't. And let me tell you, he tips his urologist.
这是一个连续镜头，当你镜头切回菲莉丝时，邓德米夫林的屏保出现了。哦，她手真快。她手真快。对。她，她把手抬起来，用左手关掉了她刚才在做的事。我对我们的摄影师兰德尔或马特说的话有着极其鲜活的记忆，他们说，嘿，菲莉丝，我们能看到你屏幕上的门。因为她连续一年都在为她的车道寻找门。哦，这笑死我了。好吧，就在这个时候，潘和吉姆在厨房里。他们没有参与把迈克尔抬起来的活动。潘向吉姆建议他们偷偷溜出去为凯文买点东西。对。在十分三十三秒，伙计们，我们知道了德怀特给谁小费，不给谁小费。我告诉你们，他给他的泌尿科医生小费。
He can't pulverize his own kidney stones and he only tips people who do jobs that he couldn't do himself. So when the sub delivery guy who was played by Justin Maloney, by the way, delivers a bunch of sub sandwiches, Dwight gives him exact change because he could have delivered his own subs. He could have. He didn't, but he could have. And then in the break room, we find out that these sub sandwiches are bologna, tomato and ketchup. Yes. That's it. There's no other options. It's bologna, tomato and ketchup. What is that? Angela, we have a fan question. This is a fan question from old man David. Okay. He wanted to know, did any of you guys actually eat any of that horrible sub sandwich? I was at Rite Aid. Do you remember, did anyone eat them
他自己弄不碎肾结石，他只给那些做他自己做不了的工作的人小费。所以当三明治外卖员——顺便说一句，他由贾斯汀·马尼饰演——送来一堆三明治时，德怀特给他的都是正好的零钱，因为他本可以自己去送三明治。他完全可以。他没去，但他本可以。然后我们在茶水间发现，这些三明治是博洛尼亚红肠、西红柿和番茄酱。是的。就是这样。没有别的选择。就是博洛尼亚红肠、西红柿和番茄酱。那是什么？安吉拉，我们有一个粉丝提问。这是一个老头大卫的粉丝提问。好吧。他想知道，你们当中有人真的吃过那个可怕的三明治吗？我在莱德艾德药妆店。你还记得吗，有人吃过吗
and were they actually bologna and ketchup? Old man David, whatever those sandwiches were, were maybe set out by craft services and people could maybe snack on them. But I don't remember the cast or crew eating them, but they never let things go to waste. If they had food that was in a scene that was edible, they would set it out over by where all the snacks were, anything that wasn't used, or they would give them to crew members. So like, if we had a scene where we had a bunch of birthday cakes, if they didn't use those birthday cakes, they would give them to people to take home. That's true. Maybe we set them out and who knows what they really were. We don't know. Yeah, maybe they were normal sandwiches, but my character Kabash is anyone
而且它们真的是博洛尼亚红肠加番茄酱吗？老头大卫，不管那些三明治是什么，可能是由剧组后勤部门摆出来的，大家也许可以随便吃点。但我并不记得演员或剧组人员吃过它们，不过他们从不浪费食物。如果他们有场景里用过的可以食用的食物，他们会把它摆在所有零食旁边，任何没有用完的东西，或者他们会把它们送给剧组人员。所以，如果我们有一场戏有很多生日蛋糕，如果他们没有用掉那些生日蛋糕，他们就会把它们送给人们带回家。确实如此。也许我们把它们摆出来了，谁知道它们到底是什么呢。我们不知道。是的，也许它们是普通三明治，但我的角色卡巴什对有没有人
eating because she's got a really crappy attitude about these sandwiches and she just makes Michael really mad and he packs them up and he's like, fine. Choke on it and he walks right out. Well, then, Angela, we have another one of Michael's sad birthday talking heads about his childhood. This time he talks about being 16 years old and how he was supposed to go out on a date with a classmate named Julie, but she went out with a different Michael from his class instead because she didn't realize which Michael she was supposed to go out with. He just has had a whole, yeah. Here's an interesting catch, Angela. In this talking head, he says he had to hear all about it the next day at school. Well, you mentioned that his birthday was March 15th. I have a Dunderpedia
吃东西很不爽，因为她对这些三明治态度太差了，她把迈克尔惹得火冒三丈，然后他把它们打包好，说，好吧。噎死你们吧，然后他就直接走了。好吧，接着，安吉拉，我们迎来了迈克尔关于他童年的另一个悲伤的面对镜头访谈。这一次他谈到自己16岁时，本该和一个叫朱莉的同班同学去约会，但她最后却和班上的另一个迈克尔约好了，因为她没搞清楚自己到底该跟哪个迈克尔去约会。他真的是经历了一整串的，对。这里有一个有趣的穿帮，安吉拉。在这个面对镜头访谈中，他说他第二天在学校不得不听大家议论纷纷。好吧，你提到他的生日是3月15日。我有一个邓德百科全书的
catch for you. Okay. They figured out that Michael's 16th birthday would have been March 15th, 1980. That was a Saturday, so the next day would have been Sunday and Michael wouldn't have been at school to hear all about it. What the heck? What? That's a crazy catch. Get it together. Get it together, writer's room. I feel like a kinship with whoever figured out this fact because of the 45 minutes I spent trying to find yams in Carbondale. Oh, yeah, you did. You looked for them for a long, long time. I did. Well, lady, you're a Pisces. You're intense and you're passionate. When the subject moves me, like, are there yams in Carbondale? Now we're at the ride aid with Jim and Pam. Yeah. Extra flirty. You haven't really had an episode in a bit where you two got to be
穿帮要告诉你。好吧。他们算出迈克尔的16岁生日应该是1980年3月15日。那天是星期六，所以第二天应该是星期日，迈克尔根本不在学校，也就不会听到大家议论纷纷了。搞什么鬼？什么？这是一个疯狂的穿帮。振作点。编剧室，你们振作点。我觉得我和那个找出这个事实的人有一种惺惺相惜之感，因为我花了45分钟试图在卡本代尔找山药。哦，对，你确实找了。你找了很长很长时间。我确实找了。好吧，女士，你是双鱼座。你很 Intense（强烈）而且充满激情。当这个主题触动我时，比如，卡本代尔有山药吗？现在我们和吉姆、潘一起来到莱德艾德药妆店了。对。超级调情。你们俩已经有一集没能有那种
just like flirty, flirty. And so I feel like probably for fans, they were so excited to be like, oh, they're back at it again. They're in cahoots. Yes, they bought 69 cup of noodles for Kevin, some M&Ms, and his favorite movie, American Pie 2. Oh, man. And then Pam even teases Jim for buying some fabric softener. Oh, she's like, you use fabric softener? And I feel like her internal monologue is like, oh, it's so cute. He does his laundry and he makes sure his clothes are soft. He's going to be great husband. I love him. Well, you know, Roy isn't using any fabric softener. Roy's not doing laundry. Exactly. Well, now next up, Angela is my favorite scene from this whole episode. No cookie. No cookie. Oh, you know, we talk about things that people will say to us
纯粹调情、调情的戏份了。所以我感觉粉丝们可能会超级兴奋地想，哦，他们又来了。他们俩串通一气了。是的，他们给凯文买了一杯69杯面的面、一些M&M巧克力豆，还有他最喜欢的电影《美国派2》。哦，天哪。然后潘甚至还取笑吉姆买了一些衣物柔顺剂。哦，她说，你用衣物柔顺剂？我觉得她内心的独白肯定是，哦，太可爱了。他自己洗衣服，还确保衣服洗得软乎乎的。他以后会是个好丈夫的。我爱他。好吧，你知道的，罗伊可不用什么衣物柔顺剂。罗伊根本不洗衣服。确实。好吧，接下来，安吉拉，是整集中我最喜欢的场景。没有饼干。没有饼干。哦，你知道的，我们讨论过人们见到我们时会
when they meet us. I get save bandit and I get no cookie. Well, Dwight and Ryan are in the kitchen and Angela enters and tries to take the cake, the birthday cake from Dwight. But Dwight won't let go of it. But she's the head of the party planning committee. It's her job to bring out the cake. Yes. And they get in a little tiff about it. And then Dwight says, hey, is that meeting to discuss finances still on for later? And Angela is like, fine, fine. But don't expect any cookie. And Dwight says, but what if I'm hungry? No cookie. And then she leaves. And then Ryan's, Ryan's expression. Ryan, oh, BJ, your look is so fantastic of like, what the F did I just witness? What is happening? But then he has that silent talking head. All of that, whatever that minute and a half of television
对我们说的话。我听到的是“救救小班迪”，还有“没有饼干”。好吧，德怀特和瑞恩在厨房里，安吉拉走进来，试图从德怀特手里抢走蛋糕，那个生日蛋糕。但德怀特就是不放手。可她是聚会策划委员会的负责人。把蛋糕拿出来是她的工作。是的。然后他们为这事起了一点小争执。接着德怀特说，嘿，那个讨论财务状况的会议待会儿还开吗？安吉拉就说，好吧，好吧。但别指望有什么饼干。德怀特说，那如果我饿了呢？没有饼干。然后她就走了。接着是瑞恩的，瑞恩的表情。瑞恩，哦，BJ，你的表情太棒了，一副“我特么刚目睹了什么”的样子。这到底是怎么回事？但接着他有一个无声的面对镜头访谈。所有这些，无论从那个场景开始到他的面对镜头访谈结束的那一分半钟的电视画面，
is from the time that scene starts until the end of his talking head is just my favorite from this episode. I loved it. It's so good. BJ's so good. It like makes it, it makes it, you know. So now it's happy birthday to Michael. The cake is out. The candles are lit. Michael is going to blow out his candles. And at the same time, Kevin gets his phone call. Is it, is it the phone call? No, it's Stacey. Stacey. He says it's Stacey. Michael is pissed because his candles aren't trick candles. And this is when everyone's kind of hugging Kevin and Michael's like, you guys stop. What is going on? Angela says very pointedly. No one cares about your birthday, Michael. Yeah. Kevin's waiting to hear if you have skin cancer, Michael. This is like, this is more important. She just like flattens
就是我这一集中最喜欢的片段。我太喜欢了。太棒了。BJ太棒了。它让，让这一切，你知道的。所以现在是祝迈克尔生日快乐。蛋糕摆出来了。蜡烛点燃了。迈克尔要吹蜡烛了。与此同时，凯文接到了电话。是，是那个电话吗？不，是斯黛西。斯黛西。他说那是斯黛西。迈克尔气坏了，因为他的蜡烛不是整蛊蜡烛。而这个时候大家都在拥抱凯文，迈克尔就说，你们够了。这到底是怎么回事？安吉拉非常尖锐地说。没人关心你的生日，迈克尔。对。凯文在等检查结果看你有没有得皮肤癌，迈克尔。这就像是，这更重要。她直接就把
it. She, I mean, she just destroys whatever good mood he was hoping to have. Well, lady, fan comments from Delaney and Kathy O'Dell, they both said, I feel like everyone was really hard on Michael. He didn't know about Kevin. And it was his birthday. Is his reaction like really that out of line? Well, here's the thing. He's being a little bit of a baby. But I think if any of us really cared about him the way we should as his coworkers, someone should have pulled him aside early in the morning and said, hey, listen, Kevin had this biopsy. Here's what's going on. We just want you to know. We don't know if you know. Yeah. Right? Right. So that in the moment, he wouldn't be such a jerk because someone would
他的兴致泼了一盆冷水。我是说，她彻底粉碎了他原本希望能有的好心情。好吧，女士，德兰妮和凯西·奥德尔的粉丝评论都说，我觉得大家对迈克尔太严厉了。他不知道凯文的事。而且那是他的生日。他的反应真的有那么出格吗？好吧，是这样的。他确实有点像个小婴儿。但我觉得，如果我们当中任何人真的像作为同事那样真正关心他，应该有人一大清早就把他拉到一边说，嘿，听着，凯文做了活检。情况是这样的。我们只是想让你知道。我们不知道你知不知道。对吧？对吧？这样在当时那种情况下，他就不会表现得像个混蛋了，因为有人已经把实情告诉他了。听着，
have let him in on it. Now, listen, he still would have been bummed. He still would have spent a ton of energy trying to make everyone like somehow find a way to be okay celebrating his birthday. Yeah, which he's going to do later. Okay. Remember earlier when I told you that behind Jim's talking head, there was a winter scene? Oh, is this the payoff? Give it to me. I want you to notice that in the background of this birthday candle scene, my cardigan is draped on the back of my chair. It's a really nice detail because if you notice at the store, I'm not wearing it. Yeah. I also want you to know that on the coat rack, in a little bit, you're going to see Pam's giant puffy coat that you're going to see her wearing
他还是会觉得沮丧。他还是会花大量的精力试图让每个人都以某种方式庆祝他的生日。对，他待会儿就会这么做。好的。还记得我刚才告诉你们的，在吉姆的面对镜头访谈背景里，有一个冬天的场景吗？哦，这就是呼应吗？快告诉我。我想让你们注意到，在这个生日蜡烛场景的背景里，我的开衫正搭在椅背上。这是一个非常好的细节，因为如果你注意到在店里的时候，我根本没穿它。对。我还想让你们知道，在衣帽架上，一会儿你就会看到潘那件巨大的羽绒服，也就是你稍后会在滑冰场看到她穿的那件，正挂在衣帽架上，还有吉姆那件又大又重的冬衣也都挂在衣帽架上。我明白这是怎么回事了。如果外面在下雪，他们为什么不带上大衣？如果冷得要命，以至于他们那天穿着厚大衣去上班，为什么潘会把开衫落在办公室，穿着一件衬衫就去逛街了？怎么回事？外面到底是冷还是不冷？外面很冷。到底哪个？有人工作时出疏漏了呗。
later at the ice rink is hanging up and Jim's big, heavy winter coat are on the coat rack. I see what's happening here. Why didn't they take their coats if it's snowing out? If it's so freaking cold that they wore their heavy coats to work that day, why is Pam leaving her cardigan behind and going shopping and just a button down shirt? What's up? Is it cold out or not cold out? It's cold out. Which one? Someone's slipping on the job there. I don't know. I don't know. I'm just saying. Okay. Well, I have a big thing to point out, everyone. What? Okay. At 14 minutes 44 seconds, Jim dares Pam to make an announcement over the store intercom because these two are like teenagers. They play jinx, buy me a Coke. Now they're daring each other
我不知道。我不知道。我只是随口说说。好吧，伙计们，我有一个重大的发现要指出来。什么？好吧。在14分44秒，吉姆激潘通过商店广播大声宣布一件事，因为这两个人就像青少年一样。他们玩“不打不相识，给我买可乐”的游戏。现在他们开始敢于互相挑衅
to do stupid things in public. Jim and Pam, what's going on? But guess what happens? What does Pam do? I know. What does she do, Jenna? She, I know Angela. She says, Luke, this is your father. Star Wars! Star Wars. She makes a Star Wars reference. Jenna, did you know what you were doing when you did it? I did because I knew from just, you know, pop culture knowledge that there was a movie from the Star Wars movies. Is it Empire Strikes Back? Yes, were they're fighting each other? Yes, and it is revealed that Darth Vader is Luke Skywalker's father. He says, I am your father. And Luke's like, no, that's not true. I knew the reference, but I did get a fan question from K Slack-ish One who wanted to know if that bit where I make the announcement was improvised.
在公众场合做蠢事了。吉姆和潘，到底怎么回事？但你猜怎么着？潘做了什么？我知道。她做了什么，珍娜？她，我知道安吉拉。她说，卢克，我是你父亲。星球大战！星球大战。她引用了《星球大战》的梗。珍娜，你做这件事的时候知道自己在做什么吗？我知道，因为我从流行文化常识中知道《星球大战》里有这么一部电影。是《帝国反击战》吗？是的，他们在互相战斗？是的，而且剧情揭示了达斯·维达是卢克·天行者的父亲。他说，我是你父亲。然后卢克说，不，这不是真的。我懂这个梗，但我确实收到了一个来自K·斯莱基什·一号的粉丝提问，他想知道我做广播的那段是不是即兴发挥的。
So the Luke line was scripted. However, I didn't improvise a little bit. So when I say I'm sorry into the mic, that was my fun idea. And it was a little nod to the movie when Harry met Sally. So do you remember the scene in when Harry met Sally? When Harry and Sally, they're singing karaoke in the store. They're singing Suri with a fringe on top. And Harry's ex-wife starts to walk up and he stops singing. And Meg Ryan is like, oh my gosh, it's my voice. I have the worst voice. And she's saying it all in the microphone. And Harry is like, no, I think I see Helen. And then really loudly into the microphone, Meg Ryan goes, Helen. And it like goes out over the store. I always thought that was such a funny bit. So I thought I'm going to say, I'm sorry
所以卢克的那句台词是剧本里有的。不过，我确实即兴发挥了一点点。所以当我对着麦克风说“我很抱歉”时，那是我的一个有趣的主意。这是对电影《当哈利遇到莎莉》的一个小致敬。你还记得《当哈利遇到莎莉》里的那个场景吗？当哈利和莎莉在店里唱卡拉OK的时候。他们唱着《Suri with a fringe on top》。然后哈利的 bývalý 前妻开始走过来，他就不唱了。梅格·瑞安就说，哦天哪，那是我的声音。我的声音太难听了。她对着麦克风把这些都说出来了。哈利就说，不，我想我看到海伦了。然后非常大声地对着麦克风，梅格·瑞安喊道，海伦。声音就在整个店里回荡。我一直觉得那是个非常搞笑的桥段。所以我想我也要对着麦克风很大声地喊一句“我很抱歉”。我不知道。我是说，可能没人会注意到。但关于你那一刻灵感的来源。我太喜欢了。我觉得太甜了。我也知道你有多喜欢《当哈利遇到莎莉》。那是你最喜欢的电影之一。女士，我上大学时，从我父母仍然居住的圣路易斯，到密苏里州的一个小乡村小镇——我在那里上大学的特鲁门州立大学所在地柯克斯维尔，需要开三个半小时的车。我打发时间的方法是把《当哈利遇到莎莉》录在磁带上。然后在我开车的时候，在车里放给自己听。整部电影从头到尾的台词我都背得滚瓜烂熟。我太喜欢了。那真是最甜的事情了。对，
into the mic really loudly. And I don't know. I mean, probably no one would ever think about it. But about your inspiration for that moment. I love that. I think that's so sweet. I also know how much you love when Harry met Sally. It's one of your favorite movies. Lady, when I was in college, I had a three and a half hour drive between St. Louis, which is where my parents still lived, and Kirksville, Missouri, which is a little rural town in Missouri where I went to college at Truman State University. And what I did to pass the time was I recorded when Harry met Sally onto an audio tape. And then I played the movie back for myself in my car on my drive. I have that entire movie memorized from beginning to end. I love that. That is the sweetest thing. Yeah,
对着麦克风大声说话。我不知道。我的意思是，可能从来没人会想过这个。但关于你那一刻的灵感。我很喜欢。我觉得太甜了。我也知道你有多喜欢《当哈利遇到莎妮》。那是你最喜欢的电影之一。天哪，我上大学的时候，从圣路易斯（我父母当时还住在那儿）到密苏里州的柯克斯维尔（我在那里上大学，就在特鲁门州立大学，那是密苏里州的一个小乡村镇），开车得花三个半小时。我消磨时间的方法是把《当哈利遇到莎妮》录在一盘音频磁带上。然后在我开车的时候，在车里放给自己听。整部电影从头到尾我都背得滚瓜烂熟。我很喜欢。这是最甜的事情。是的，
I recorded on my tape recorder, David Letterman's opening monologues. And I would play them back and listen to his opening monologues. Oh my gosh. Well, you said you wanted to work for a late night talk show. I wanted to work in comedy. Yeah, comedy late night. Yeah. Yeah. Lady, look, we were meant to be BFFs. We were both driving in our cars, listening to things we recorded off of our TVs because we're 100 on our tape decks. Lady, I just got a text from Lee. He sent me a photo of... Is this about your breath? Yeah. Can I go down and check it out? Can we take a break? He made sandwiches for the kids. I want to see if they like it. Oh my god, he did it. Way to go, Lee. But did they eat it? That's the question we'll find out. All right, we'll be right back.
我在录音机里录下了大卫·莱特曼的开场独白。然后我会放出来听他的开场独白。哦天哪。好吧，你说过你想为深夜脱口秀节目工作。我想从事喜剧工作。对，深夜喜剧。对。对。女士，你看，我们注定是好闺蜜。我们当时都在车里，听着从电视里录下来的东西，因为我们骨子里就是百分百的磁带时代。女士，我刚刚收到李发的一条短信。他给我发了一张照片……这是关于你口气的吗？对。我可以下去检查一下吗？我们能休息一下吗？他给孩子们做了三明治。我想看看他们喜不喜欢。哦天哪，他真的做了。真有你的，李。但他们吃了吗？这是我们要找出的问题。好的，我们马上回来。
We're back. Bread report for everyone who's curious. It's freaking delicious. I just ate a slice. Is it? It's good. I don't know if the kids are going to eat it. What is their deal? You know what, Angela? They love all of my other breads. They love my sourdough bread. They love when I make rolls. They love when I make popovers. For whatever reason, I cannot get them to like my sandwich bread. They just want store-bought sandwich bread. I've tried three different recipes. Today will have been my third sandwich bread recipe. I don't know. Or they will like it the day it comes out of the oven, but the next day, it's a no-go for them. They only want it warm out of the oven. I don't know. Shall we get back into this episode, Milady? I think we should. Where
我们回来了。向所有好奇的人汇报一下面包情况。好吃的要命。我刚吃了一片。是吗？很好吃。我不知道孩子们会不会吃。他们到底怎么回事？你知道吗，安吉拉，他们喜欢我做的所有其他面包。他们喜欢我的酸面包。他们喜欢我做的卷饼。他们喜欢我做的泡芙面包。不管出于什么原因，我就是没办法让他们喜欢我的三明治面包。他们只想吃买来的三明治面包。我已经试了三种不同的食谱了。今天将是我的第三个三明治面包食谱。我不知道。或者他们会在面包刚出炉的那天吃，但到了第二天，他们就坚决不吃了。他们只想吃刚出炉热乎的。我不知道。我们该继续看这一集了吗，女爵士？我觉得我们应该继续。我们在
are we? I believe that we are back in human resources. 15 minutes, 15 seconds. Kevin is talking to Toby about his skin cancer. Yeah, and this is a nice call back to season one's health care episode because Toby's like, can you get on your fiance's health care plan because honestly, ours is horrible. That's right. To me, it was a nice call back to the health care episode. Well, Michael comes over with a bunch of facts that are about why Kevin shouldn't be worried. He's got some statistics. The subtext is why we can still celebrate Michael's birthday without any problem, but he's presenting it as why Kevin shouldn't be worried. Yeah. And then Toby's like, you know, kind of gives him some Toby's ass. And Michael's like,
哪？我相信我们回到了人力资源部。15分15秒。凯文正在和托比谈论他的皮肤癌。对，这是一个对第一季医疗保健集的完美致敬，因为托比说，你能加入你未婚妻的医疗保健计划吗，说实话，我们的太糟糕了。没错。对我来说，这是对医疗保健集的一个很好的致敬。好吧，迈克尔带着一堆事实走过来，解释为什么凯文不该担心。他有一些统计数据。潜台词是为什么我们仍然可以毫无问题地庆祝迈克尔的生日，但他把它表现为为什么凯文不该担心。对。然后托比就，你知道的，给了他一些托比式的回怼。迈克尔就说，
why are you here? And Toby's like, I work here. Well, now Michael is going to announce that they're going somewhere and it's to make Kevin feel better. There's an outing for the whole office. But of course, if you remember in an earlier scene, Michael asked Dwight if he's made all the plans for later. So this is clearly been in the works. Oh, there's a big banner when we walk in says happy birthday, Michael. Like this was planned for sure, not by the party planning committee. By the way, Angela would not allocate funds to this. No. But Dwight had this, he had planned it. We had a fan question from Noel, Angela, because we're about to go to the ice skating rink now. And that's the big surprise that he's taking us all ice skating. And Noel wanted to know,
你为什么在这？托比说，我在这里上班。好吧，现在迈克尔要宣布他们要去某个地方，这是为了让凯文感觉好点。这是整个办公室的集体出游。但当然，如果你还记得早些时候的一个场景，迈克尔问德怀特是否为之后的活动做好了所有安排。所以这显然早就已经在筹备中了。哦，当我们走进去时，有一个巨大的横幅上面写着“祝迈克尔生日快乐”。就像这绝对是计划好的，绝不是聚会策划委员会干的。顺便说一句，安吉拉根本不会给这个批预算。没有。但德怀特有，这是他计划的。安吉拉，我们有一个来自诺尔的粉丝提问，因为我们马上就要去滑冰场了。那是他带我们去滑冰的巨大惊喜。诺尔想知道，
did you have a safety meeting about ice skating? Remember, safety meeting lit candle. I'm sure we did. I'm sure there was a safety meeting about we have heavy things being held on the ice. I'm sure there was all kinds of safety meetings. Well, I know we had a medic there. And the reason that I know this is because I don't know if you remember, Angela, but Mindy fell while we were shooting. I don't remember that hurt her knee. So you know, there's that little bit at the ice skating rink where Kelly is helping Ryan. Yeah. Well, she fell and she hurt her knee and the medic had to give her some ice, but she was able to finish filming. Her knee was okay. I thought it was interesting when you saw the different couplings of people ice skating. In
你们开过关于滑冰的安全会议吗？还记得安全会议上点燃的蜡烛吗？我确信我们开过。我确信肯定有一场关于我们在冰上拿沉重东西的安全会议。我确信有各种各样的安全会议。不过我知道我们在现场有个医疗急救人员。我知道原因是因为我不知道你是否还记得，安吉拉，但明迪在拍摄时摔倒了。我不记得那件事了，她伤了膝盖。所以你知道，滑冰场里有那么一个小片段，凯利在帮瑞恩。对。好吧，她摔倒了，伤了膝盖，医务人员不得不给她一些冰块，但她还是坚持完成了拍摄。她的膝盖没事。我觉得当看到不同配对的人在冰上滑冰时很有趣。在
the beginning, you see Kelly and Ryan, you see Pam and Jim. I sort of just kind of go around solo. Yeah. So this Dwight, we just kind of, we don't, you know, want anyone to know we're seeing each other. So we skate alone. And then later you see Ryan and Phyllis holding hands and ice skating. Yes. At 19 minutes, we had a fan catch by KP who said, I love when you see Ryan and Phyllis at the skating rink holding hands so Ryan won't fall. It's such a random glimpse into their friendship. I think Angela, they did that because Mindy was icing her knee. And what's really cute if you watch it is Phyllis is so tickled. She's so tickled. It's just really cute. It's very, very sweet. And I actually, I went back after I read that comment and I watched it and it's really very
一开始，你看到凯利和瑞恩，你看到潘和吉姆。我差不多就是独自一人到处转转。对。所以这个德怀特，我们只是，我们不希望任何人知道我们在交往。所以我们独自滑冰。然后后来你看到瑞恩和菲莉丝手拉手在滑冰。是的。在19分钟时，我们有一个来自KP的粉丝穿帮发现，他说，我喜欢看瑞恩和菲莉丝在滑冰场手拉手，这样瑞恩就不会摔倒了。这真是对他们友谊的一个随机一瞥。我觉得安吉拉，他们这么做是因为明迪在给膝盖冰敷。如果你仔细看的话，非常可爱的一点是菲莉丝觉得太逗了。她觉得太逗了。真的非常可爱。非常非常甜。而且实际上，在我读了那条评论后，我又回去看了一遍，看他们两个一起滑冰真的非常
sweet to see the two of them skating together. So that was an accident. I had another fan question from Live Long California. Did you and John know how to ice skate? Or did you have to learn for this episode? So here's something interesting. In this episode, Jim is kind of helping Pam on the ice. But right before we filmed this episode, I had actually been in some intense ice skating training because I was filming a movie with Will Ferrell called Blades of Glory. And yeah, every Saturday morning for a few months, I had to go early in the morning and spend about three hours learning to ice skate. And the crazy thing is my character didn't even ice skate in the movie. I am completely pretending to not know how to ice skate in this scene on the office because I had actually just,
甜。所以那是个意外。我收到了另一个来自“长命加利福尼亚”的粉丝提问：你和约翰会滑冰吗？还是你们为了这一集不得不学？所以这里有个有趣的事。在这个场景中，吉姆在冰上有点在帮潘。但就在我们拍摄这一集之前，我其实一直在接受密集的滑冰训练，因为我要拍摄一部由威尔·法瑞尔主演的电影叫《冰刀双人组》。是的，连续几个月，每个星期六早晨，我都得早起去花大约三个小时学习滑冰。而疯狂的是，我的角色在电影里甚至都没有滑冰戏。我在《办公室》的这个场景里完全是在假装自己不会滑冰，因为我其实刚刚，
I mean, kind of learned how to ice skate quite well thanks to this movie training. You're describing my fantasy. But all I ever wanted was to be cast in something where they're like, listen, Angela, you're gonna have to learn kung fu. You're gonna go every Saturday. You're gonna become a kung fu master. Or you're gonna have to learn how to throw an axe. You're gonna get really good at throwing axes. Like I wanted to learn something like that. But it's never happened. Well, speaking of skating, Michael is zipping around in his hockey gear. So in the background of Michael's talking head, it's around 17 minutes, 42 seconds. There's a really great shot of that professional ice skater, Bert Lankin, who stands in for Oscar. He's doing
我是说，多亏了电影训练，我已经把滑冰学得相当不错了。你简直是在描绘我的白日梦。我一直以来的愿望就是能参演一部剧，剧组对我说，听着，安吉拉，你得去学功夫。你每个星期六都要去。你要成为一个功夫大师。或者你得学会如何投掷斧头。你要变得非常擅长投掷斧头。就像我一直想学这种技能。但从来没发生过。好吧，说到滑冰，迈克尔穿着曲棍球装备在冰上飞驰。所以在迈克尔的面对镜头访谈背景里，大约是17分42秒，有一个非常棒的镜头，是扮演奥斯卡的替身、专业花样滑冰运动员伯特·兰金。他在做
a bunch of twirls. It's just sort of fun. You realize nothing with you though, Ange. I know nothing with me. But do you realize one of the office members who's not on the ice is Creed? And it's because he's in the arcade playing a shoot-em-up game with a bunch of kids. Oh, yes. That's right. That's right. Well, there's also that scene where Michael checks Toby into the wall. Yeah. We had a fan question from Cardinals fan. Was Toby harmed in the making of that scene? No. And if you watch closely, Steve's body never really touches Toby. Like he really, like Steve, I think because he's so good, he kind of slams into the wall and makes a noise with his arms. And then Paul just sort of falls to the ground himself. No, Steve had total control,
一连串的旋转。这只是挺好玩的。不过安吉，你得明白，这可不是针对你。我知道，这不针对我。但你有没有注意到，办公室里没上冰的成员之一是克里德？那是因为他在游乐场里和一群小孩子们玩打僵尸的游戏。哦，是的。没错。没错。噢，还有迈克尔把托比推到墙上的那一幕。对。我们有个来自红雀队球迷的粉丝提问。拍摄那一幕时托比受伤了吗？没有。如果你仔细看，史蒂夫的身体其实根本没碰到托比。就像他真的——我是说史蒂夫，我想因为他演技太好了，他只是猛地撞向墙壁，然后用手臂制造出声音。接着保罗自己顺势倒在了地上。不，史蒂夫完全掌控了，
but it's because he's such a good skater. And so he could definitely sort of show off a little bit and do all that stuff. Oh, this was for sure one of Steve's favorite film days, I think. I mean, it had to be. He was having the best time. Yeah. And also, he had the best time because Nancy Carell, his wife in real life, shows up in this episode again as Carol Stills, the real estate agent. She's at the ice rink. But Michael's so innocent. He's like, oh, was this for sale? And she's like, no, Michael, I can go places that aren't for sale. You know, like my kids are here to ice skate. And then he's so sweet with the kids. He's so sweet. And we sort of learned that Michael probably could have tried to play professional hockey, but he didn't think
但那是因为他滑冰滑得太好了。所以他绝对可以稍微炫耀一下，做所有那些动作。哦，我觉得这绝对是史蒂夫最喜欢的拍电影的日子之一。我的意思是，肯定是这样。他玩得太开心了。对。而且，他之所以玩得最开心，是因为现实生活中的妻子南希·卡瑞尔在这集里又出场了，饰演房地产经纪人卡尔·斯蒂尔斯。她在溜冰场。但迈克尔太单纯了。他说，噢，这个是要出售的吗？她就说，不，迈克尔，我可以去那些不对外出售的地方。你知道的，比如我的孩子们来这儿滑冰。然后他对孩子们太温柔了。他太温柔了。我们还了解到，迈克尔本来可以去尝试打职业冰球的，但他觉得
it was a great job to have if you want a family. And that's all he wants. So it's just this theme again that Michael just wants a family. That's what he wants. Well, you know, when he offers to pull the kids around the ice rink with his hockey stick, he's skating backwards and he's pulling the kids. Lee does that all the time with our kids. Aw. So when I saw that, I was like, oh, I think that's like a hockey guy thing to do. You pull your kids around as they hold onto the hockey stick. You just turned into like a 16 year old girl with googly eyes. You just thought about your husband. I know. I wish you could have seen Jenna just now. She just literally did this weird thing with her shoulder and she kind of tossed her hair and she was like, I think it's a hockey
如果你想要一个家庭，这不是一份好工作。而这正是他想要的。所以这又是一个主题，迈克尔只是想要一个家庭。这才是他想要的。你知道的，当他提出用冰球杆拉着孩子们在溜冰场上转圈时，他倒着滑冰，拉着孩子们。李经常对我们的孩子们这样做。噢。所以我看到那个时，我就想，噢，我觉得这就像是冰球运动员会做的事。你拉着你的孩子们，他们抓着冰球杆。你刚才简直变成了一个双眼发光、16岁的小女孩。你脑子里只想到了你老公。我知道。我真希望你刚刚能看到珍娜。她刚才真的做了一个很奇怪的耸肩动作，然后她甩了甩头发，说了一句，我觉得这是冰球
guy thing. Like it was, what just happened to you? Clearly, clearly when you saw your husband do that, you were like, yales. Yales, baby. I get real smitten with him sometimes, especially when he does, you know, when he's on the ice fathering. Yeah. The ice being a great dad. Okay, now Kevin gets the phone call. Everyone skates around him. Jenna, I remember filming this because we had to time it out. And there were a bunch of us on the ice that skate up to where he is. Do you remember this? Yes. And we have to all be able to stop. I didn't know how to stop. Yeah. That was my one problem. I didn't know how to stop. So I remember trying to like push really hard to slow myself down. So I didn't run into people, but I was like stressed out. Well, guess what? His results are
运动员才会做的事。就像是，你刚才怎么了？显然，很显然，当你看到你老公那样做时，你会想，耶。耶，宝贝。有时候我真的迷恋死他了，特别是当他做那些——你知道的，当他在冰上扮演父亲的时候。对。冰上好爸爸。好了，现在凯文接到了电话。所有人都围着他滑冰。珍娜，我记得拍摄这个镜头，因为我们得掌握好时间。我们有好多人在冰上，一直滑到他所在的地方。你还记得这个吗？记得。而且我们都得能停下来。我不知道怎么停。对。那是我的唯一问题。我不知道怎么停下来。所以我记得自己当时拼命想用力推冰来让自己慢下来。这样我就不会撞到别人，但我压力好大。好吧，你猜怎么着，他的检查结果是
negative, which is a good thing. You want your Michael to understand that. No, Michael's like Michael is he's like, Oh, no, this is horrible. We're going to beat this. And he has that amazing talking head where he's like, it turns out that in the medical field, negative is a good thing. Now in the real world, negative means bad. But when it comes to test results, it was it was it was one of those that you love, Angela, where he's describing things to us that the rest of us all know. And one of my favorite things is when Michael is like, I'm going to break this down for you. Yeah, this is what it's like information. We all know coming as a surprise to you too. Yeah, I know. I'm going to tell you. Yeah. Yes. Well, now we're opening gifts lady.
阴性，这是一件好事。你得让你的迈克尔明白这一点。不，迈克尔就像——迈克尔他觉得，哦，不，这太可怕了。我们要战胜它。他有个超棒的单人访谈，他说，原来在医学界，阴性是件好事。但在现实世界里，阴性意味着坏事。但说到检测结果，这绝对是安吉你最喜欢的那些时刻之一，他向我们解释了我们所有人都知道的事情。我最喜欢的时刻之一就是迈克尔说，我要为你们剖析一下。是的，这就是信息。我们所有人都知道，但这好像也让你感到很惊讶。是的，我懂。我要告诉你们。是的。好吧，现在我们要拆礼物了，女士。
I know I love this scene. We're opening gifts. I have actually been in the room where we filmed. I'd been there before because I'd been to a kid's birthday party. And if you have a kid's birthday party at this particular rink, number one, your birthday child gets to ride the Zamboni around the ice one time. Oh, yes. And then you get to have all of your birthday cake and presents in this room where we were. So it kind of cracked me up that this is where Michael's birthday would be because he's so childlike. So we're sitting at this table. Kevin gets a card that says get well soon or something like that. But it's got a lady in a bikini. This clearly made his day. He's going to save that. Maybe he'll put it with some of the things he keeps on his computer because
我知道，我超爱这个场景。我们在拆礼物。我其实去过我们拍摄的那个房间。我以前去过那儿，因为我去参加过小孩子的生日派对。如果你在这个特定的溜冰场举办小孩子的生日派对，第一，你的过生日的小寿星可以坐着赞博尼冰面平整车绕冰场转一圈。哦，耶。然后你就可以在这个我们所在的房间里吃生日蛋糕、拆礼物了。所以这让我觉得挺逗的，迈克尔的生日居然会在这种地方过，因为他太有童心了。所以我们坐在桌子旁。凯文收到了一张卡片，上面写着祝早日康复之类的话。但上面印着一个穿比基尼的女人。这绝对让他的一天都美滋滋了。他要把那个收好。也许他会把它和保存在电脑里的一些东西放在一起，因为
he's a little pervy. He's very happy about this card. He loves it. And then Michael gets a Wilkes Berry Penguins Hockey Jersey from Dwight. This is a real team. It actually, well, and it says from Dwight. From Dwight, number one, I have been to their rink, me and Craig Robinson, Brian Baumgartner, Kate Flannery for the first ever office convention. We got to go. We got to go on the ice. We all got a jersey. I still have my jersey. That's amazing. Yeah. So they're the AHL team. So they're not the NHL team. They're the AHL team. And that's, yeah, real hockey team. Real hockey team and their mascot is Tux the Penguin. Everyone there was really, really nice. That was, that was super fun. Well, then Pam gives Michael night swept. From everyone. It's big. So
他有点色眯眯的。他拿到这张卡片非常高兴。他太喜欢了。然后迈克尔收到了德怀特送的一件威尔克斯巴里彭兴斯冰球队球衣。这是一支真正的球队。实际上，而且上面写着来自德怀特。来自德怀特，第一，我去过他们的冰场，我和克雷格·罗宾逊、布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳、凯特·弗兰纳里一起参加了有史以来第一次办公室年会。我们去了。我们走上了冰面。我们都得到了一件球衣。我到现在还留着我的球衣。太棒了。对。所以他们是美冰联的球队。所以他们不是国家冰球联盟的球队。他们是美冰联的球队。那就是，对，真正的冰球队。真正的冰球队，他们的吉祥物是企鹅图克斯。那里的每个人都真的非常好。那真是，超级有趣。嗯，然后帕姆送了迈克尔Night Swept古龙水。来自所有人。这很大。所以
it's from everyone. Yes. Yeah. Yes. From everyone in the office. We had a fan question from Boss Lady. Is there really a cologne called night swept? Well, there's not. But Jenna, did you know this is a callback? Did you catch this? Yes. Yes. From hot girl. When they're cleaning out his car. Yes. In season one, episode six, hot girl, Ryan and Michael are cleaning out his car. And Michael says, that's my Dracar Noir, right? Is that how you say that? Yeah. And Ryan's like, no, it's ride aid night swept. And Michael's like, uh-uh, it's a perfect smell alike. I'm not paying for the label. So he's probably very excited. He likes night swept and he already is a buyer of night swept. And here he gets a four pack. He got lotion, cologne, some kind of body spray maybe.
这是大家送的。是的。是的。是的。办公室里的每个人送的。我们有一个来自“老板娘”的粉丝提问。真的有一种叫Night Swept的古龙水吗？嗯，并没有。但是杰娜，你知道这是一个前后呼应吗？你注意到了吗？是的。是的。来自“辣妹”。当他们清理他的车时。是的。在第一季第六集《辣妹》中，瑞恩和迈克尔正在清理他的车。迈克尔说，那是我的Drakor Noir，对吧？是这么发音的吗？是的。瑞恩说，不，那是Rite Aid的Night Swept。迈克尔说，呃-uh，闻起来完全一样。我才不会为商标花冤枉钱。所以他可能非常兴奋。他喜欢Night Swept，而且他本来就是Night Swept的买家。在这里他得到了一套四件套。他得到了乳液、古龙水，可能还有某种身体喷雾。
Yes. That was all packaged and created by Phil Shea. That is a fictional cologne line. However, I just want to let you know that I did Google night swept and there is a Christian based mystery novel by writer Marvin Rehm. Okay. Called night swept and it's available on Amazon. Okay. Okay. There you have it. For super fans out there who might want to read a book called night swept. Night swept. It doesn't smell like anything from what I would assume since it's a book and it's not a cologne. There you go. There you go. Where are we? It's the end of the episode. That's it. Cam ends this episode with a talking head. She says it was a good day. Angela, because of what you said earlier, which is that, you know, finally we get a little flirty flirt for her and Jim.
是的。那是菲尔·谢伊打包制作的。那是一个虚构的古龙水系列。不过，我只是想让你们知道，我确实谷歌了一下Night Swept，有一本由作家马尔文·雷姆创作的基督教悬疑小说。好的。叫做Night Swept，亚马逊上有售。好的。好的。就是这样。对于可能想读一本叫Night Swept的书的超级粉丝来说。Night Swept。据我推测，既然它是一本书而不是古龙水，它闻起来什么也没有。给你。给你。我们到哪了？这集结束了。就这样。帕姆以一个单人访谈结束了这一集。她说这是美好的一天。安吉拉，因为你刚才说的话，你知道的，最后她和吉姆终于有了一点小小的调情。
They got to go shopping. She got to learn he uses fabric softener. I mean, this was a good day for Pam. She got to pretend what it would be like maybe to be Jim's girlfriend for a day and Yeah. Run an errand. Run errands together. And she loved it. She loved it. So it was a good day. And Michael had a great birthday as it turns out. He got to ice skate. He got a present he liked. Kevin was going to be okay. So it all ended well. It did. But before we say goodbye to Michael's birthday, there is a deleted scene that I have to read. I'm not going to tell you anything about it. It's a Dwight talking head. I'm going to read it and then I'm going to just watch your reaction. Okay. All right. Okay. This is okay. Deleted scene of a Dwight talking head
他们一起去购物了。她了解到他用衣物柔顺剂。我的意思是，对帕姆来说这是美好的一天。她可以假装体验一天做吉姆女朋友的感觉，而且，跑腿。一起跑腿。她喜欢这样。她非常喜欢。所以这是美好的一天。事实证明，迈克尔度过了一个很棒的生日。他去滑冰了。他得到了他喜欢的礼物。凯文会没事的。所以这一切都有了一个好结局。确实如此。但在我们向迈克尔的生日告别之前，有一个被删减的片段我必须读一下。我什么都不会告诉你。这是一个德怀特的单人访谈。我要读一下，然后我只是看你们的反应。好吧。好的。好吧。这个可以。德怀特单人访谈的删减片段
from Michael's birthday. Michael's birthday is hard for me because he gets very excited. But he's also under a lot of pressure, which builds up until he's ready to explode. As his right hand man, it's my job to release that pressure so that he can enjoy himself if only for a moment. Wow. That is brilliant. That is brilliant. That is a delightful, delightful talking head written by Lee Eisenberg and Gene Stepnitsky. Right? That's right in their wheelhouse. But you know, it probably was hard for Rain to get through that. For sure. Guys, that's it. That's Michael's birthday. We celebrated Michael's birthday. Happy birthday, Michael. We hope you had a good time. Thanks for coming along for the ride. Next week,
来自迈克尔的生日。迈克尔的生日对我来说很难熬，因为他会非常兴奋。但他也承受着很大的压力，这种压力不断累积，直到他准备爆发。作为他的得力助手，我的职责就是释放这种压力，让他哪怕只享受片刻的快乐。哇。太棒了。太棒了。这是一个令人愉悦的、令人愉悦的单人访谈，由李·艾森堡和吉恩·斯普尼茨基编写。对吧？这正是他们擅长的。但你知道，雷恩要演完这个可能真的很不容易。绝对的。伙计们，就是这样。这就是迈克尔的生日。我们庆祝了迈克尔的生日。生日快乐，迈克尔。希望你过得愉快。谢谢你陪我们一路同行。下周，
we're going to do some drug testing. Dwight, why is your urine green? We'll find out. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of the show and our bonus episode's candy bag, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们要进行药物检测。德怀特，为什么你的尿液是绿色的？我们会找到答案的。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、杰娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版节目和我们的彩蛋集糖果包，请访问StitcherPremium.com。若想免费试用一个月Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码 Office。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。